foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign
[Music]
and we are live with game two day two if
you will of round three with me here is
women's world champion hoeython efon
it's it's been it's been a minute since
you and I hosted a show together but uh
I'm so excited for today's action
hi Danny hi everyone yeah actually I
thought so we we had some broadcast
together maybe last year or maybe even a
year before yeah
the uh the World Chess Championship in
2018 for sure we had uh we had a lot of
time and a lot and some great times
covering it uh joining me and Robert but
um today I'm sure we're gonna have a lot
of exciting games more than just one
game to cover with the fide World Cup
and uh
yeah I'm looking forward to it so I hope
you are as well and let's uh let's
remind everybody of what's ahead the uh
the the format here is is is quite quite
complex but obviously the World Cup is
known as uh maybe the most exciting
knockout that exists in chess uh right
now we are in the uh 96 players left in
total between the open and the women's
section 64 players respectively and the
open 32 in the women's and uh
yeah so what what uh when you look at
the time control longer games this isn't
rapid and Blitz online chess uh Yvonne
have you have you been enjoying the the
high quality chess so far with all the
days you've had covering it with uh
Donya nariditski
yeah definitely and here we have the
let's say longer and classical games
definitely the quality are much higher
but even when they're doing the tie
breaks I think I joined the fabric of
round two still there are many good
games let's say with brilliant ideas and
so on
yeah some some incredible games
including some some wild Armageddon
finishes as well so it's been it's been
I've been watching as a fan and it's
been it's been exciting
um the prizes of course are also a lot
of a lot at stake here for these players
you can see respectively fifty thousand
dollars for first place in the women's
section 110 000 in the open and uh and
yeah as we move on here the stakes only
get higher and uh and yeah so the um
the schedule here is going to continue
to be busy so for those of you wondering
we have two days now uh back to back and
then we will have our first rest day
actually coming up on July 21st so
that's not a typo there the Gap will be
and the rest will be well deserved
especially for for people like you Ethan
who've been here pretty much since the
beginning with with Donya
uh well actually I joined the first day
and then uh I was here for like for five
four days don't remember exactly and
then drawing the exactly on the day of
primary conference too yeah
well we're still early here and the
games will be starting in T-minus about
seven seven minutes let's remind
everybody who's who's tuning in early in
in our audience on on Twitch of one of
the story lines we've been following
throughout the event has been the
different streamers that are well known
to the uh to the community it's it's
been interesting to see uh some of them
some of them stick around we've got
Geary and mamagara but I think
interestingly Magnus Carlson also
technically technically a streamer
although not that often isn't
necessarily on the list but um if on
maybe maybe we need to just have you
start streaming and then you can play in
the Fida World Cup next time and get on
this list what do you think
uh well I thought that uh become a
streamer is more likely than compared
compared to play the next World Cup
and what what is that what are your
plans right now as far as a return to
maybe high level professional chess any
any plans in that regard
um well actually we're going to have a
national games that we still start or it
will start the day after tomorrow's
actually today I just traveled to the
place uh but this is not exactly the
highest level of transformment but on
the other hand it's important for Force
I guess for Department in China they
normally consider this kind of let's say
um game sports games the more important
than this individual sports tournament
right so if talking about the chess
tournament uh you know professional
level there are nothing planned yet at
this moment as long as you keep playing
and winning the women's speech Yes
Championship every year like you just
did then I'm happy
um and congratulations on that by the
way thank you all right well before
before we uh take our first break and
then come back to the game starting
let's also remind everybody that uh
Vichy Anon speaking of world champions
we are here with hoefan today vishi will
be joining us tomorrow uh so you can uh
Circle your calendar for that and and
make sure you're you're tuning in for
the uh for the champ who will be tagging
in for refawing on the back half of
tomorrow's show but okay so on that note
it's it's time it's getting getting time
for the games to begin we're getting
excited here we're going to take uh our
our last break before the first move is
played here it's game two of round three
the 2021 fide World Cup more action when
we return
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the uh live cameras there from the from
the playing Halls do you do you miss do
you miss being in environments like that
these days you fun
well definitely I mean
if recalling my last tournament
it's well back to 2018 I guess if we're
talking about some high level chance of
course I play some games in the
different leagues but that's all the
same thing and if the venue like this
like such a that's a huge event probably
even longer probably the only Olympiad
bike to 2016. I'm not so sure about it
already that's a long long time and it's
very happy to see such an event happens
after the year of pandemic right so I
guess only maybe even many active
players they're not playing the venue
with the hundreds of players right
now it's a good point and on the on the
subject of the pandemic we just saw our
first awkward handshake of the day there
between Jeff arenoff and Peter schidler
with the uh not quite sure what to do so
they ended with a fist bump it looks
like um but now we've now we've switched
over to uh where where all things start
and begin and and the high levels of
Chess that is with Magnus Carlson who uh
got game one against aryantari uh for
those who maybe didn't tune in yesterday
uh Magnus took took the W with the white
pieces and now is facing one E4 and has
responded with C5 against his fellow new
region so
is it is it ever awkward to play your
own countrymen in an open tournament
like this where you could play anybody
do you ever have that or is it just all
business as usual regardless
oh well actually we actually came to
this question even yesterday with Daniel
but so I think Daniel approached me in
different way I have similar experience
even in the final match of Women's World
Chess Championship back to the time that
I first launched in the year of 2010. so
in yeah in the final match I played with
my uh teammates so uh I wouldn't say
it's completely the same there might be
some difference because you'll know each
other better right and you came from the
same country that somehow a little bit
so well I don't know how to explain
exactly but uh let's say it might affect
your performance but I don't think
that's a very let's say a deep deep
level because as we can see the Magnus
performance yesterday
uh he got the game slow but later on he
showed his tactics right and had a kind
of nice finish yeah at the end with a
chat only seven but today I choose with
E4 not sure if it's an evil player
yeah
Magnus Magnus is for those who just
tuning in Magnus pause for a minute
after E4 by by Ariana before playing the
move C5 and and of course we see them
making moves now but note that note that
he did not play uh the suspension cough
which is something that we've seen
Magnus employing
um at least semi-regularly since the
2018 World Championship match versus
carwana instead he chose E6 which has
some potential some potential to
transpose later on but after the open
Sicilian and Knight to C6 uh right now
we're headed for some sort of Timon of
Sicilian potentially so interesting
right maybe maybe ariane's surprises
surprises Magnus a little bit with E4
and then Magnus takes a moment to to
decide not to play the special
uh well he still got the chance to play
so I shouldn't come with some will not
have sex here as Tara just played noisy
three but we if he went went for this
move older the only reason is that he
doesn't like to reach some positions of
96 Bishop B5 I think I was just about to
show that yeah to show what do you find
saying if Knight to C6 is played you
have Bishop to B5 and you're in rosalimo
moskova types of Sicilians so Magnus
saying he's not interested in that but
as if on said if Knight F6 is played
Knight to B5 D6 Bishop F4 and E5 we can
actually transpose into
um the mainline special coffin in a
variation like this so okay we'll we'll
see we'll see what Magnus chooses to go
for it but
we play this very often right I I
remember very rarely
no you're right a6's A6 is officially
saying he's not interested in
espechnikov
um for whatever reason right now and
maybe just not even not even gonna toy
around with whatever aryantari might
have prepared and and now we are 100 of
the time off I can't remember Magnus
playing a Time on off Sicilian in recent
memory at all can you no well I I I'm
not so sure for the last two or three
years as I'm not really up to date about
in the previous decade also because I
applied with Magnus a couple of times
and while I'm doing the preparation I
don't even remember that I paid a single
attention to temanov or Sicilian in this
way I mean in general I'm not Sicilian
but recently he starts to play uh sushi
nikov so that's that's one of the
direction but here
um it seems like he's in a situation to
play for a week I mean if we only look
from opening perspective but in reality
not so maybe he he decided to go for the
sewing case to play against Terry
probably he thought that Tower is not a
let's say really comfortable with this
type of structure or the essence of the
position
yeah I uh agree agree agree totally and
um Ariane obviously now taking a think
it's early in the game but and when top
players are thinking like this it's not
that they don't know their Theory but
obviously they're trying to think way
way ahead right in regards to what they
prepared especially if your opponent
um surprises you a little bit with a
move order wants to make sure he gets he
gets all the right variations against
the time on off
um
yeah and also he needs to choose between
the long castle and the short Castle as
there are many different lines here I
mean different setups for white yep
yeah and that's a big philosophical
decision right we know that Tori is is
in a must-win uh game because he lost
because he lost game one yesterday but
still
um choosing choosing the right approach
here there are there are big decisions
here whether it's Bishop to E3 or Bishop
E2 can already be indicative of the type
of Timon of Sicilian that REM wants to
get so well why don't we why don't we
maybe maybe try to come back to that I
also wanted to check in on a game
um well I wanted to check on Fabiano's
game if if we if we can do that
um
oh but yesterday he he drew or yeah he
drew
yep Juma bayev um he uh
who's a regular regular uh player in a
lot of chess.com events jumbo on on
chess.com and and we haven't had as much
carwana as sometimes we get in top
events because of the the situation
where his opponent was forfeited due to
a positive a positive covid-19 test so I
just thought it might be interesting to
check in on this nothing nothing
spectacular yet
um a transposition into kind of a an
orthodox Queen's Gambit and anything
jump out to you about this particular
position
oh well too early to say I mean nothing
special right it's just a kind of
typical structure and why this I'm
planning to play 90e took short Castle
maybe F3 E4 or I mean that's the idea
that uh White Delights the development
of Knight F3
right
yeah so the the move order here is
specifically designed to keep that
option open right is there are there
still chances in some of these lines
where White's going to Castle along
uh well yes I think at some moments and
they've still got like a H3 G4 but after
you constantly uh why you need to pay
attention with some C5 B5 B4 so right uh
this is the double aged decision
yeah and sometimes I feel like the move
order here is particularly tricky just
because it gives your opponent a little
bit more to think about uh rather than
playing the straightforward line even if
you did decide to transpose into
something with Knight F3 and not go for
Knight E2 but obviously uh jumbo is uh
is gonna have to really make sure he he
gets the line that he wants against the
well-prepared Fabiano caruana
um it's hard when your Republican uh
naturally plays everything right right
what what do you do against someone like
that against I mean carwana is obviously
I don't know if this is necessarily true
but he he has the reputation
to as as being one of the one of the
most versatile and well prepared right
there are well-prepared players like
Maxine Bossier the grav who are a little
more known for their particular weapons
right whether it be the Knight or the
grunfeld and then there's players like
carwana who just have the reputation for
being super deeply prepared but also
very hard to pin down what what do you
do against an opponent like that
well uh I guess if I face a player like
Karana who who has a very good and deep
home preparation and huge uh let's say
opening repairs also I probably just
think a little about what I'm going to
do that's it and even spend less time
less time on preparation
okay because even if you spend time I I
don't think you know with limited amount
of uh work you put on it you could let's
say prepare for something
so better just to focus during the game
I think that's more important but that
also depends on the style because I'm a
kind of person you know not that hard
working on only openings
right I mean not to no need to compare
with the top level players like you
mentioned the uh Karana or mul but even
compared to some just Grand Masters I
thought they probably could work even
harder so I think I'm more like a
practical player of some sense but
that's interesting advice you kind of
gave if I'm reading between the lines
just about sometimes against the player
the right approach is to not spend too
much time stressing in the opening right
and be well rested or be well prepared
just to just to play a hard fought game
rather than trying to pin them down
right it gets a guy like harwana that
might be your approach
yeah definitely but on the other hand I
mean we expressing this way but on the
other hand if you get into your
opponent's preparation that would be
very tough I think I had similar
experience when playing with top guys I
mean if just a strong Grandmaster even
if you get the worst Precision still got
chances but against top players it's
like once you've got worse they simply
give you zero chance to fight it back so
that's a tricky point so we need to be a
bit smarter clever just to make sure
that you enter into the direction that
could enter into a balanced middle game
that's important but how it's a good
technical question
yeah I mean it makes sense one of the
fun facts just show just shown there by
the team is you and I were correct so it
wasn't we're always you know not 100
confident when it comes to saying things
about Magnus Carlson's chess because
he's the world champion but we were both
corrected we had never seen him play a
Time on off and in fact he has never
played a Time Monarch before so kudos to
us that we weren't crazy about that and
that'll be interesting to see for those
who just tuning in just quickly Flash
the board again Magnus Carlson employing
a timonoff and has his opponent Aryan
tari in in uh in thought currently after
the move A6 but but okay we'll come back
to that let's let's go over to a game
also of one of the top boards so we
haven't checked in yet uh the uh
maybe the most the most well-known uh or
most followed troll on social media of
the top players in the world that being
a niche Geary he's he's several moves
um several moves down the road here
against the one of the most talented uh
players up and coming from Uzbekistan
um Abdul satoroff uh norderbeck abdusa
turov is uh although we see there's so
many talented players right now uh
coming coming and rising up from from
Uzbekistan but here this looks like it's
about to be a very sharp game a
well-prepared game against uh Geary
yeah it's French oh uh first of all I
don't think Gary plays E4 very often he
did but uh
I don't think it's his um most popular
weapon but maybe he did this on purpose
I have no idea uh what is the let's say
no no more openly repetitor from the
Young's Pakistan player but seems like
Alice was expected wasn't ready for this
or maybe he's not ready for Bishop
December C8 because it seems it seems
new to me a Twist yeah we know they're
C4 there's not there's a knight H6 here
but for Bishop D7 just to Simply a line
before in the play Rock C8
yeah
yeah this is not in fact I was I was
just giving a um a lesson to one of the
players playing in our in our tournament
Arc uh tournament very different levels
of Chess obviously um with with our um
fighting game Community streamers and
Anime players but talking about Black's
idea to play A5 to prevent B4 precisely
being one of one of the key points
blackoff and employs here but here as
you said Bishop D7 allowing allowing B4
and then playing Rook to C8
very a very different approach and and
we see that uh Anish is the one on the
clock here the higher rated player
trying to figure out how he's going to
navigate this
um black has a couple different ideas in
these lines to play A5 still where you
put this Knight is going to be really
key in terms of how black approaches
these positions and sometimes still F6
right so this is kind of a flexible
approach from Medusa turov even though
white is a little bit better in these
positions
yeah I think the next couple moves will
be important like then you mentioned the
white needs to figure out what type of
setups he would like to approach because
these three is where we cannot uh let's
say go immediately but if we support it
with Bishop B2 then the special B2
Bishop is somehow under the eye of the
queen on B6 there might be some
sacrifice or 85 at different moments and
if we first develop the light Square
Bishop like Bishop E2 then we might lose
the control of F5 Square then black may
have 97 95 ideas so uh why would be
happy to bring the Knight to C5 let's
say C3 A4 OD to B3 but that also seems
like a long way to be there
so what are in in these types of
positions because of what you said right
the bishop on B2 there's there's
potential tactics on B4 it also makes A5
a little spicier
there are times where white will just be
willing to allow Knight on F5 and put
the bishop on E3 right like positions
like this where the the structure is one
that is it okay for white if these
double pawns occur because it reinforces
protection here or is this is this not
the idea for white uh definitely it's
possible because if we compare it with
one of the main theories after A3 black
got the move Knight H6 B4 then C takes
D4 then C takes D4 Knight F5 yes
yeah and then white has two options
Bishop B2 and Bishop E3 so once you
bring them back to E3 is very similar
like you know other positions in the
game right uh so here I don't think I
mean even if we get back to the position
it's unlike that black will do the
exchange immediately because
it's at his hand he can do when whenever
he wants right he probably needs to
develop first because once open up the f
file and the double even here the phone
is really supports the D4 and the black
may get some pressure
among the king side due to this point E5
and the black spaces are somehow
um centralizing on the queen side
right
okay
well all right so Gary Gary is uh is in
thought here
um against this against this move order
I don't know how often Abdus has played
a friend you asked that question uh
quickly at the at the top of of the show
when we first switched to this board I
know I know he is a regular E5 player I
can say that just from knowing some
online games he also on the white side
of these positions is known known for
some funky some funky Scotch openings
and I I remember that because I I play
it myself at times so but I but I don't
know how often he's played the French
maybe we'll check on that and and see
how this game develops
um
and okay why don't we why don't we head
back to the game at the top of the open
section here where Magnus Carlsen again
has played a Timon of Sicilian for the
first time in his career for those who
are just tuning in it uh not only took
us a little bit by surprise but the
quick storyline of this game recap was
Ariane played the move E4 and Magnus
thought for a minute because Ariane is
not the most traditional E4 player
played C5 but then did not go into the
svenikov that we've seen Magnus playing
regularly and instead played a Time on
off
um and this is where we stand uh if on
he uh Aryan played Bishop F4 that's not
the most common move here no
normally why do Bishop is real Bishop
b203 but
I think similar ideas haven't happened
in different system variations like
router or
I mean different opponents so this is
definitely an idea but just it happens
here at this moments
uh yeah not sure at least not the most
popular ones but after this oh yeah he
played D6 yep and then Ariane captures
and is immediately played queenity too
so
it's it's funny because on a structural
level this isn't the most abnormal thing
you would see and and white is is kind
of doing things that are sort of what
you see but the but the unique position
of the bishop on F4 versus where it
traditionally is either on E3 is
is definitely going to lead to some
spicy positions right away if white does
cast along or even put a rook on D1 the
decision comes early in terms of what
exactly do you do with D6 are you
playing D5 are you playing E5
um
but a funny position to be so early on
and not really be in Mainline Theory at
the v-day World Cup
yeah seems like
[Music]
a plan needs to push E5 if you push D5
oh well there's certain challenges
because the bishop is only four
yeah hard to tell it's just a different
phone structures I mean E5 looks more
natural to me that allows 9 F6 so Bishop
B6 Bishop seven uh and in that structure
white could even think to Castle short I
mean depends right then Knight A4 C4
right if we're gonna maintain the space
advantage and stop the uh let's say
breakthrough on the center with the move
D5 then why they would be happily to con
gather control for the full game right
yeah
so black is
so what if black does play just normally
here like so I
I mean I don't think you want to play
Knight F6 in some of these positions
because of an immediate E5 kind of
strike could could sort of split these
pawns right this is a this is one
positional break that white has
so something like Bishop E7 and what if
white just goes all in and Castles long
you need five D5 or E5 E5 okay
Bishop retreats to E3 or G3
E3 looks like
the Knight F6 yeah because for this
structure White Castle Law I'm not so
sure
what happens here because the black is
fast to play Rook B8
Queen Beast uh Queen A5 and song
right it's like a it's it's it's weird
because it's it's like a lot of types of
Sicilians when you see this structure
and you think okay white just has an
English attack idea and and black just
has a night or kind of element but it's
not exactly like those because like you
said Black is Black is actually very
quick in these positions and probably
would even neglect castling for some
time because there's no need black would
immediately be looking for pressure over
here on the queen side
yeah but on the other hand maybe a wife
could try Bishop C4 at the earlier stage
just to be able to manure I mean
transfer this bishop to B3 covers the B
file and also stops A5 A4 Strat from
black and also keeps eye on the D5
breakthrough yeah and then there's some
other idea with F4 immediately just to
try to you know the knob or F5 G4 comes
up so it's hard to say to be honest I
like this move Bishop
Bishop to C4 is uh normally that's a
move you see like in a Yugoslav dragon
or something but not not
necessarily what you would always see on
the white side of a of a Timon of
English attack or a night or but here
here it makes a lot of sense stop Bishop
E6 and to be in a more defensive spot
yeah
um okay wow well this is this will be an
exciting one and I guess if you're
thinking about it from Ariana's point of
view knowing you're in a Muslim
situation against the strongest chess
player in the world that's not the
easiest situation to be in right
um but uh
but this is going to be a double-edged
game right yeah I feel like a tower
should be happy that he got this
position
[Music]
wouldn't be the most comfortable when he
gets into this position I guess because
there might be some counter play complex
positions and the players could easily
lose of control
right
okay well um remind everybody there's
obviously a lot of games going on
um right now we are we are just underway
here game two uh in round three game two
here at the feeder World Cup uh you can
go to chess.com events if you have to
happen to be tuning in on Twitch or
YouTube or anywhere
um and you want to you want to watch a
different game Yvonne and I will do our
best to follow all the most exciting
moments but there are a lot of games and
there's a chance sometimes we may not be
covering
um the uh the most the most exciting
game so
um
so okay let's uh let's continue to to
bounce around
I haven't I haven't seen the face of the
person we just brought up on camera so
I'm not not exactly sure which game
we're showing and head over there bro I
have no idea which board and who's on
the Y side
I think that's Cavalia
so I'm gonna bring up cavalia's game I'm
I don't you know I'm I think I know the
faces of a lot of top chess players I'm
not not everybody is immediately
recognizable to me
um it's also been about a year and a
half since we've seen any of them on
camera because of the pandemic so but I
think that's Cavalia
why you imagine that uh we haven't seen
them from camera for one and a half year
I just thought okay they probably could
be a completely different person right I
mean you know you never know but I think
I guess right and I was there was no
name but okay there we go we've got
Cavalia uh completing here competing
here against Bobby Chang
um obviously for those who've been
following the whole the whole event you
know the storyline uh in that uh Mr
Chang did receive a forfeit win
um because of uh levada Roni and
withdrawing due to due to health
concerns and so
um
here we see Bobby Chang on the black
side uh of this position versus cavaliav
well the last one will be three seems
seems quite unusual
yeah B3 is a move order let's talk a
little bit about that actually
um
the uh
the the Carroll Khan transposing into
kind of a reversed sort of Orthodox
Queen's Gambit structure a kind of a
minority attack that could ensue for
black on the queen side when you get
this move order with Queen C7 keeping an
eye out for the idea that eventually
black sometimes strikes with B5 and B4
in these positions and so the move B3
is is a flexible one where white is
actually preparing to kind of change the
structure with C4 in a lot of ways and
maybe that's if we take a look at this
position if on it's kind of like the
setup that carwana has employed but with
covers reversed right
uh the difference is Bishop on C8
instead of G4 that actually matters a
lot yeah
because one Bishop
we should move outside to clearly there
will be some initiatives but when it's
at home it's different and also these
three as then you mentioned the
preparing scene for the things like
interesting yeah though I thought if
it's necessary at all
yeah it's in some ways it's kind of a
defensive move too right because I guess
if black ever plays for a minority
attack if the pawn did extend maybe then
you could respond with C4
um but it's
it's weird white wasn't maybe sure how
to develop the bishop on C1 obviously
there's limited options and even if you
go to G5 there's no real relocation
because black is already holding the G3
square and you've expanded here so
perhaps just not quite sure how he wants
to approach developing the queen side
place this move B3
and also well there's one here we see
for the other idea probably Knight A3
Knight C2 to do this 90 manure because
we're to develop this B1 noise is
another question
yeah
if you go to D2 F1 then the same problem
you cannot go to G3 so right maybe no I
don't see two would be heavy replies
keep an eye on B4
yeah it's really interesting because
this whole sort of sequence was set up
oddly enough by the move 6h3 right white
white commits to the line H3 to prevent
Bishop G4 but in turn leaves the G3
Square slightly less defended I know
that 92 is actually the most popular
move here theoretically I believe and
and white tries to play things like
Bishop F4 there are lines like this
where Bishop G4 F3 uh black doesn't play
Bishop H5 for example because of Knight
F4 and so the main theoretical move is
actually Bishop D7 and that that kind of
ends how well I know these lines in my
just off the top of my head but but to
play H3 instead of Knight E2 is to avoid
all of these things
and
and that's where we get this position
where as you said he found the G3 square
is now no longer protected so plans like
this and plans like this
are not really on the table
okay
well
uh
we have a look for other games maybe we
can have a look for
um I think he's a popular he's the
highest rated player who lost the first
game
um again he uh he lost on day one uh
game one as game one of round two as
Yvonne just mentioned to the to the
young hike Marty rosian who's uh very
well known to the chess.com Community
currently competing in our in our Junior
speech Yes Championship
um and is a a very talented Blitz Blitz
and bullet player for sure
um
so he won he uh hike won game one and
this was actually the final position you
saw where he was just up a lot of Pawns
and Black's King was open so Mama jar of
threw in the towel here we have game two
look how far along they are this is this
is an end game already
wow
what game approached here I'm just
wondering because the worldwide could be
so he better but you know in muscle wind
situation
don't think it's a very
promising game for white
yeah I agree and um you know knowing
that Mama yarov is down a game so again
in the format that means he's in a
muslin position he does have the white
pieces but this is not a game with a ton
of Promise the bishop pair I guess holds
some long-term chances but the blacks
pieces are super well coordinated right
I mean the night is the night is in a
great spot you'd love to put the pawn on
H6 but you're too slow for that black
can deal with that in a number of ways
even just King G8 or something so
so yeah I'm with you although I have
been told that we have we have one crazy
game we should probably go to
is it already
is it already over
wait
that's the penkos game
[Music]
completely really what happened
oh no no that was from I'm sorry I was I
was looking at the previous round we've
got the full archive here so no but oh
my gosh this is the this is the current
position
against uh the Grand Master abasa from
Azerbaijan
um
what happened here Wow Let's
have sex and like we're discussing the
Magnus game and finally we got one and
why it takes on C6
that particular line
sorry I don't know the name of the
variation yeah well this is the time
honor um and again
um if this had happened in the Magnus
game maybe we would have seen Knight to
B5 trying to transpose into special cops
but Magnus didn't allow it
um again if you're just Tuning In the
comparison was we had a traditional time
on off but here Knight C6 is played
asapenko captures on C6 E5 this is this
is a main line
but I'm I'm not exactly sure when the
theory ends here C4 check and then King
E2 uh
still Theory King E2
and F5 and then this is all still Theory
Knight of two Bishop A6 and then King F3
this is all this is all actually here
after Knight F2 okay but I knew before
Knight F2 yes there's this variation but
I'm not sure if that's a main one
well according to our database here and
I'm just following the Insight the the
Eco
this is a position that has still been
played hundreds of times actually and
black black plays 97 which is indeed the
main move Bishop to E3 is is the the
mainline response so nothing nothing
about this position is actually new yet
as wild as this looks Queen A4 Bishop B7
now H4 is actually the first novelty in
the game played by the young Russian
escapenko until the until that move
according to our database Queen A3 B4
and Rook D1 have all been tried so H4 is
a novelty according to the status but
maybe we'll get one of our staff members
checking on that um checking all
different databases to ensure but your
thoughts about this position regardless
of the fact that until H4 it was
actually Theory
oh well I I just feel like oh why it got
a very promising position despite the
King on F3 about the skin safely placed
here H4 probably just keep an eye on G5
and also leave this H2 for the king case
he wants to you know Escape because the
black Superstition has some let's say
long-term weakness the D7 Pawn D6 Square
bad Bishop on B7
uh yeah so maybe black needs to move the
queen away and try to push C5
like for example Queen B6 here but even
after C5 white gold King G3 King safely
place here so you can just
you know develop
yeah like well here b2's being hit so
white could even play Queen A3 which is
a typical movement just to show your
point if C5 check is played King to G3
and white is white is still just fine
right
yeah in general I feel like I could put
like Black's position would be very
tricky because of this C6 weakness and
D7 so that cause black no counter play
yeah because there are no lines so
yeah and it's it's funny with the pawn
on C5 you actually limit the Queen's
gaze which one of the only things
keeping White's position a little
dysfunctional is that the queen is is
hitting these squares
um
so makes me think is there an idea like
Queen D4 in some positions where you
gain a Tempo and try to play C5
um
piece
uh Queen B3 uh Queen B3 is key because
you defend and hit the I was just about
to say you can't play a normal move or
you know some other move like Rook D1 or
something because then C5 check comes
and queen E3 is is devastating
yeah
yeah uh yeah but you can go Queen
Queenie for Queen B3 Rock ba through
Rock D1 and then C5 King G3 because
queen of B3 defends both B2 and E3
so that makes next move Rook D1 possible
okay
it looks like according to this and I'm
making sure it looks like they actually
did play
they actually did play Queen to B6 and
C5 check in the game
oh it happens in the game yeah it looks
like this is the live position and um
again there's still so many games going
on at this stage in the fide World Cup
we don't have live cams necessarily of
every single board
um so uh as the games go on and we know
which games will be the most exciting
you tend to see the roaming cam on site
uh fide's Team working hard to give us
all the possible live feeds so that's
why we've had a look at Geary while
we've been analyzing this but on that
note
the stage has been set here for game two
of round three ephon we're going to take
our very first break since the games
began so don't go anywhere everyone a
lot of interesting action ahead Magnus
Carlson plays the Timon of Sicilian for
the first time in his career sfpenko's
King is on a walk and we're gonna be
right back
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
and as we come back here to game two of
round three defeated World Cup we've
been covering a lot of magnus carlsen's
games uh game against Ariana just like
we'll be doing coming up in November the
2021 World Chess Championship Match
awaits us we will have live feeds of the
playing Hall on Twitch exclusively no
other channel on Twitch will have the
the camera's up close and personal with
yawn and Magnus so tune in hit that
follow button if somehow you haven't
already and uh let's jump right back to
the game that is live right now at
defeated World Cup Magnus Carlson is
this time on off a sign of things to
come will he be playing it in the future
or was it just something to avoid
whatever prep his younger Countryman
came up with again for if you're just
tuning in A6 was played by Magnus
Carlson in this game confirmed the first
time in his career playing the Sicilian
and we have this weird line Ethan since
we left it E5 was played kind of as you
predicted now Knight F6
H6 and Bishop E6 so again very
interesting this is a sicilian that is
not structurally very odd but the
particular move order in the way we got
here is not something you see every day
no and then no that then transposed to
somewhere else there but definitely not
exactly the same position
and I don't think to be honest that I
I'm not so sure why why the is
Bishop on H4 right because this p is not
something very annoying for black and
also at some moments where I could try
G5 trying to you know fully restrict the
activity of the stocks for a bishop and
then he could create 0p8.85 but uh yeah
just like how I develop because you
don't you don't have F4 here you
probably need to go F3 G4
I just didn't see many good plans for
white in this current position
yeah
um agreed agreed it's it's awkward it's
it's it's interesting H6 itself is not
always the best pawn because if G5 does
occur we have kind of an anchor to blow
things open but like you said White's
position also awkward and it's not going
to be so clear especially with black
probably accelerating the attack even
faster than you get in some Sicilians so
all right a lot ahead in this game we're
gonna bounce around a little bit more
quickly reading reading the chat and the
tea leaves real quick appreciation to
everybody no matter where you're tuning
in from we see you in a lot of games to
look at I want to jump to the game
between uh two countrymen as well we've
been following two Norwegians closely
let's go look at two players from India
Vida Gujarati who who was a guest of a
guest yesterday uh got the win as white
and now has the black pieces and a sharp
Sicilian against uh against adibon
he's uh known as known as a beast he
plays some beastly chess sometimes and
this is a sharp position here
[Music]
a clock yeah and the position itself
also looks okay for black it might end
as soon because if white cannot create
something in the next few moves the
position would just be I think
simplified yeah and that's exactly what
bit needs again because he got the win
in the first one as you pointed out the
clock is sort of telling the story that
bit is in his in his preparation so
we'll just quickly look at it uh we had
a symmetrical English until E5 was
played here by Mr Gujarati and now the
capture and D5 wow what a a fun little
way to get almost like a tarash a
symmetrical cement with the e-pawns
being traded this is not something you
see every day and
and here we go
um
what are White's options to get it to
get something spicy before like you said
we just trade and maybe black even has
Bishop B4 check coming
yeah maybe how about the most simple one
like nine F6 then Bishop
somewhere Bishop at four right
takes takes especially before there's
maybe this chat
yeah I don't think like Chuck Bishop D2
yeah
just trying to exchange your materials
because they've got four isolating poles
but here yeah black structure is no good
if if white can survive the opening but
can white survive the opening right yeah
I was just thinking like property three
could be
an option oh wow what a crazy move to
stop the Bishop from developing too
well only your mouse uh touched this D4
Point realized
option right yeah the C4 Pawn is under
attack so something like this and even
Queen E7 is coming and you've got
weirdness okay well wow this is
this is going to be a fun one to keep
our eye on as well so especially for all
the viewers from India I'm sure watching
this closely vid it but it of course the
favorite right he is the higher rated
player among the two but
um just checking in on all those battles
where you've got a couple people from
the same country but let's let's go to
another game that had a lot of attention
yesterday another matchup if you will
between uh Niels grandilius and Jeffrey
Zhang uh grandelius won a really
interesting end game down down a piece
there toward the end but a bunch of past
pawns so he has Jeffrey Zhang in a
must-win position here with the white
pieces
um also looks like a bunch of theory
given the way the players have managed
the clock
um it's hard for white to win though he
got an extra pull or backward we had to
be maneuvering the Knight to C4 and just
stay there but of course the white
custard and trousers
yeah good point the extra Pawn but not a
very easy position to play this is such
a simple plan for black how do we get
here this looks like it was probably
okay yeah it was a grunfeld some sort of
weird grunfeld
but transposes
just taking a peek yeah this is like
this is all Theory here this is a line
that that like you said the dynamic is
very clear white has the extra Pawn but
Black's position is super easy to play
all the pieces are completely primed for
a really easy plan and Jeffrey's gonna
have his work cut out for him if he's
going to win and send this thing to tie
breaks
oh we'll see well I think
I think our match situation uh why they
would be very happy to play this
position you know it's really requires a
very sophisticated skills to uh
to transfer the material to a full point
Ultra black will be you know play easily
you just need to stop the pole and throw
in some positional move and wait for a
while to see what's next what do you do
in that situation as a mindset I mean I
feel like as a commentator never played
it at that high of a level when you're
talking about must win situations
because we talk about the psychology
knowing that it's it's much easier said
than done right you know you're in a
must-win situation so you have to win
but objectively if you get too careless
then you lose and and maybe quickly
right so what what is is there like is
there like Mind Tricks you play with
yourself to keep yourself in the right
in the right you know state if you're in
a situation that's must win
yeah I think you're right some a very
good question actually that's um I said
one of the skills that the player uh
would be much stronger if you know how
to deal with the situations it's very
hard because in a muscle in situation
you need to let's say have the balance
have this Turning Point like okay what
are the boundaries you could try
something aggressive you could try to
find four choices but can't be too much
so for example as a black if you start
with some crap positions you probably
would lose simply because you are your
opponent doesn't know how to play chess
but if you play something very solid
especially with the black pieces you
know it's very hard to win so I guess
you need to
um play a normal game but in the
meantime trying to avoid those forcing
variations that could simplify the
position immediately
but that's let's say something
theoretical in a practical game is very
hard especially nowadays when people
study a lot in the opening
uh so if I was just like thinking my
personal experience most of the time I
wasn't to put myself into the situation
most likely also like I want the first
game and somehow lost the second game
bring myself to the tie Break
um but I remember clearly once in the
World Cup that's very interesting we got
to the toy break
uh maybe that's my first award come
against uh and my opponents was
knowledge and I thought it was there was
like two games Ty break therefore I lost
my first game with white and then this
in the second game I choose some very
sharp Sicilian variations I think
English attack and trying to complex the
position but after the game I realized
oh there will be four games of Tyrek
inside of two so I guess my opponent was
somehow shocked to see that after losing
the first game in the four game match
they started to do something very sharp
right
yeah that's crazy the the uh
the situations are like you said just
just not easy
um maybe a little bit easier I guess
when you have the white pieces in a must
win but not not much especially like you
said with preparation
being so deep and navigating
um navigating uh with the computers they
they know how to get positions that are
really tough tough to hard to lose so
grandelius as the stats showing a second
to Magnus Carlsen in the 2018 World
Chess Championship also one of the best
Bug House players in the world for those
who don't know what bug house or Devil's
chest is you can you can play it on
chess.com and it's it's a lot of fun but
he's actually uh known as maybe among
among strong Grand Masters I know
levonne aronian might disagree with that
do you ever play Bug House
oh I played but just for fall not many
not very often but I also the first time
I knew that he's a very strong bathhouse
just yeah
yeah he's he's very good very tricky but
okay we've been talking about Jeffrey
Zhang uh the former World Junior
Champion is in a Muslim situation also
in a muslin situation is another Junior
nihal sarin who lost his first game
against Dimitri on draken but in an even
worse position I guess um from a from a
practical point of view he now has the
black pieces against on draken uh let's
not forget how how great on draken has
been historically in the World Cup right
he's a former finalist in the world cup
and uh what did is there are there
certain players who tend to play better
in this type of format
um or sometimes is it just a bit of uh a
bit of you get the right pairings in in
an event that is just so incredibly
difficult
um and things work out but what are your
thoughts on that some people
stylistically do better in these types
of kind of large knockouts
well I guess in the in the open section
parents really matters really matters
because uh not only to say that you are
in a let's say a strong uh let's say
part of the weaker part because the you
know all the parents was arranging a
very fair system right but just like the
opponents you might you might face uh
are the one whose style is in your favor
or who probably got a better score
against you it's basically about
individuals so that's one thing
and the the other thing well the other I
don't think there are many other points
the other points are just saying how to
perform well by yourself and how to be
ready for the tournament with such a
tight schedule
uh but in women's section I guess that's
something different I I guess if you
just focus on yourself trying to be
stronger then probably you could do
better because we have I mean in the
women's section they're less strong I
mean let's say less number of
participants
and also the average strengths are not
in the same level compared to the open
section
no it makes sense
um in a large event like that pairings
really matter and then you just and then
it's just about whether you're playing
well right and uh in that sense I guess
nielle starring got a tough pairing
because Demetri on draken seems to be
playing well and likes this format let's
go over to prognananda's game um the
other young man from India who has
everybody watching he took down
krasenkoff in the um the first game
and uh krasnikov sent home uh Korea
Alexa Yenko uh the the wild card from
Russia who played in the candidates
earlier this year with an incredible
game one of my favorite games as I
tweeted out last night of the event so
far where he sacked The Rook on H6 was
awesome but but here krasenkov is uh
down already one game and
what's going on here this is wild I I
think black should be fine despite the
King on D7 because White's King is also
in a bit of trouble here but your your
thoughts on what we have on the board
it seems like the game will finish suing
your drawer I I mean I'm not so sure but
looks like although why they're gonna
extra look but your C1 C3 weakness might
allow black to give some checks along a
to Knight A4
uh so I guess we need some accurate
calculation to see to see how game
continues probably if white could
successfully bring his King to F4 then
G3 he could got some chances but
unlikely really unlikely
let me show that line uh something like
this she was you were she was kind of
saying and if Queen A4 you know the
point is this would be a draw which
means if you commit to King D2 you're
probably going for a king walk but okay
no wait the computer says no there's
some sort of win here just sort of check
and then what is it some sort of oh
checkmates okay so that that doesn't
actually work so that means what you
said is probably true the the game is
because how else are you defending C1
right the only moves are King D2 King D1
and as you said this is
probably just a draw unless you're
unless you're super into checkmating
yourself right so there you go well
after Queen A4 maybe you could try King
E2
okay Queen a4k okay that makes sense
right and now because now Queen C2 you
can play Bishop D2 right yeah
yeah about going the three probably also
a Perpetual check right check
breaking the one Queen B one Bishop c
one Queen B3 yeah yeah
like checks everywhere I think you're I
think your instincts were correct Prague
just might be about to punch his ticket
into round four with this uh with this
draw because again
uh he won he already won uh the first
game of round three so
um
what a story that would be who who of
all the young future maybe World
Championship candidates that the world
follows will get furthest in the in the
World Cup praga's Prague is playing
exceptional chess right now
um
okay wow that'll be that we'll keep our
eye on that one again if you're just
tuning in we see a lot of questions
following the chats you can go to
chess.com events and uh follow the games
yourself and then yell at us if you see
a game that you that you really want us
to go to we're going to continue to
scroll around
um
so many games let's go let's go check on
uh ship Arena and Peter Fiddler how's
that sound
hey
for those who just got here they had the
most awkward start of the day the fun
fun handshake where they didn't know
what to do and ended up with a fist bump
which seemed seemed agreeable so uh we
haven't checked in on this game at all
and uh it hasn't hasn't actually moved
along that that far except that Peter
Fiddler is down almost 40 minutes on the
clock here
well his position looks quite promised
promise yeah
I like this night
I also would love to get Queen H5 and
Knight G6 Checkmate that sounds fun
yeah but they always be Queen E8 well
I'm just curious which opening is some
Berlin or what yeah let's look real
quick we'll look in
see how we got to the live position here
we had a Roy Lopez a Berlin
specifically okay
a main line Berlin but yeah this is a
sharp position we have on the board
given that sometimes you see them okay
Bishop A4 that was the
that was the move right the most the
most Mainline move here of course is to
capture C6 and take E5 for those who
know their Berlin Theory but uh Bishop
A4 instead
stop me stop me if you have any any
thoughts about this position you find
I'm just trying to catch us up
uh
at the moment
try just trying to get the key points of
this position
yeah it looks like Peter has now played
the move Knight to D5 so he doesn't go
for my my Checkmate threat of Knight to
G6 unfortunately
um but Knight to D5 is on the board and
okay here we have uh
Black is Black is up a pawn here that
doesn't immediately meet the eye because
you see Black's lack of development and
this D7 Pawn is is a forgettable one but
black is up a pawn so white has to prove
some sort of pressure with the pieces in
the center here
and also he might have some plants a
moment
56 but you also face clingy eight so
darn it you keep stopping the Checkmate
let me just show it for fun because I'm
like I'm like a kid in a candy store I
can't stop it so night there and there's
our Checkmate takes takes and queen H5
this is always fun when you've got
things like this on the board so okay
but like you said if if anything is
played on Knight F4 Like Queenie Queen
E8
probably black is just fine
is there some other move besides what
other move would we play here I mean you
could also you can also trade I'm just I
I keep playing B6 because I'm thinking
about how to solve the development
problem but what are your thoughts when
you're playing the black side of a
position like this to just sort of
squelch your opponent's initiative and
then convert your extra Pawn
yeah I mean it's really hard to play
with black probably
I might also consider Bishop F6 it's
just trying you know to get these pieces
out
uh trying to be concrete and the force
the opponent to make some decisions but
I agree B6 is a completely different
style and that mind works pretty well
because also it's unlikely to know
what's next from White
yeah I like your Bishop F6 I think also
the the risk of of trading here is then
you have to then you have to retreat
your night but maybe you can get away
with something like this because the
night blocking you can maybe even play
like some weird move where you just go
up to the epon this feels good for white
um but it's black like maybe five yeah
maybe
I don't know
you could also just trade the bishop I
guess but okay
um
Knight to D5 and
okay chaparinov has indeed played the
move B6 which was my
my suggestion so naturally the engine
doesn't like it that the engines don't
normally like the chessboard size
because I see his clock is still running
so or he's still thinking
I think oh wait did he did he actually
play oh no wait he didn't play B6
I think that's probably our analysis so
yeah
okay so this is still the this is still
the live position he has not played B6
okay
my my apologies and and we see that the
engine didn't like it and I it's
actually because of this move Queen H5 I
think and now suddenly
now suddenly it's harder
okay yeah we'll just if you play Queen
E8 now we have problems because trading
you have to take with the Rook taking
with the Knight
would allow white to trade on C6 and
then win the bishop for free on E7 so
taking with the Rook would allow this so
that is that is why B6 is not a good
move
foreign
we've been we've been bouncing around
here a lot
um
we can uh we can continue to do so maybe
check back in at the top of where things
start here go see what's going on in
Magnus Carlson's game it's been a it's
been an interesting one from a
preparation standpoint for those just
tuning in Magnus Carlson playing the
Timon of Sicilian for the first time in
his career ever and now we have a uh
we have a sharp one aryantari is in a
must-win spot with the white pieces
because he lost game one yesterday
because he
he starts with A5 A4 but a bit slow yeah
I I was anticipating kind of what you
were saying initially just Rook B8 and
queen A5 is a more but okay the problem
whenever you put your pieces in front of
your pawns if you don't get anything you
kind of you know like King B1 you lose
your chance to create more stuff so
sometimes rushing the pawn to try to pry
open more files first it's just sort of
the the simple approach
I guess he's pointing out that
Ariana's attack on the king side is not
as aggressive as you might normally see
in an opposite side Castle's game right
he doesn't have the English attack Pawn
storm
coming so quickly so
yeah probably a good thing for G4 here
but uh
half a Z5 then take some gate four
yeah what if we any place can be one
this is kind of typical prophylactic
well if we just go down like obvious
roads and and maybe it's it's too much
analysis at this point but if we go down
obvious roads who's winning the race it
feels like black is and which is not
what you always say in these positions
and in fact if the Knight is unpinned
kind of a common trick if you're ever in
these positions as a viewer where you
gain a Tempo and your opponent has to
deal with Checkmate now you can actually
move this Knight because it's unpinned
and suddenly Knight C5 and A4 and it's
like all of Black's pieces are just
coming together against the B Pawn as if
as if it was planned all along so this
is this is something I think Tori has to
watch out for is is it's not
not so simple if all of Black's pieces
quickly come to life especially with
this Knight D7 trick the moment that
it's unpinned
yeah that's a good idea that's a lot of
the night of the queen
A4 and the B3 would be the targets
yeah
all this is is that the one white World
develop his king-sized attacks because
if you just wait here and allow black to
slowly slowly slowly improve and then
all right
well
um wowzers we got a lot of stuff ahead
again we just checked in on a ton of
games remind you once again you can go
to chess.com events and Choose Your Own
Adventure if you need to I think when we
come back we'll check back in on
essepenko's game with the interesting
king walk and definitely uh tune into a
few that we have not looked at yet I see
radislav uh what toshik's game is also
sort of heating up so don't go anywhere
more with me and women's world champion
hoey fun it's the fide World Cup game
two of round three and we'll be right
back
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and we are back here live with game two
of the fide World Cup let's remind
everybody before we jump
right back into the games we're gonna
head over to the women's section for the
first time today but mark your calendars
for the month of August we always think
of August as St Louis month because you
start with the rapid and Blitz and then
ultimately move to the sinkfield cup so
gonna be a lot of fun we will have full
coverage of both of those events part of
the grand chest tour right here on
chess.com so mark your calendar for that
but let's head over to the the women's
section if on where we have not tuned in
yet today
um starting on board one you have uh
garage Kina versus badelka a a situation
once again a must win for Olga with the
white pieces
looks
looks like garajukina is going to make
that make that tough this is a pretty
pretty unclear position but she's uh
she's doing fine on the clock and should
be about equal with black as long as she
handles this direct threat on the C6
Pawn right now
uh yeah I was just going to say I simply
the four to disappear okay so maybe we
have the idea like
B5
that seems like a very obvious but we
need to think about
B5 coin
D1 where does the queen go does she does
she go to B4 because I really like your
B5 and if like if B5 Queen A3 I assume
black hasn't moved like Knight C4 or
something and this is
this is probably bad news but maybe
white is actually just fine in some of
these positions because the C6 Pawn is
is actually so weak I don't know but
but you could also just defend the pawn
right I mean like something like Queen
to D6
what do you think uh yeah oh I was just
thinking what happens if
Knight C6 Bishop D7 and the ninth be ah
95 Bishop
C6
yeah so we cannot capture the pawn
agree uh but after Queen D6 how about
the bishop A3 I actually didn't see that
yeah that looks bad for black
because where does the queen go
if you go to
maybe you can just go to C7 though
but like
like white just brings a rook to C1
this is
I mean vadelka does have some pressure
here this is maybe harder than first
meets the eye I thought black should be
fine but C6 is
kind of hard to defend
yeah the first song we saw black should
be okay as there's all this a file
against the coin and only physics is
weakness well later we realize this now
I know A5 actually badly placed
and we need to deal with B6 C6 E7 like
three weakness on the same times and I
assume something like B5 just can't be I
assume white could probably just take
here I don't yeah maybe not but
felt like this end game should probably
get you get a whole bunch of Pawns but
maybe maybe you don't want something
like this you cannot capture E7 yeah
Knight D5 okay got it and if the rock
Bishop f8 so it just got one extra pole
maybe not enough
so B5 but I guess just the same thing
you said before B5 the queen can just
move in a lot of these positions and you
haven't actually solved the problem of
this Pawn being horrible whether it's
yeah yeah
and now Knight takes B5 is of course a
very strong threat
okay wow well
this is yeah black needs to just uh
think about a good plan for at this
position I mean where to move the coin
whether to push B5 or
what's next so that's actually very
important
okay well garage keynote is uh
uh maybe maybe right now the the the
strongest active active uh women's
player in the world and she's she's the
highest rated player in the feeder World
Cup so with with having already won the
first game
we'll assume she's going to figure this
out we got a lot of other games to look
at here in the women's section let's
just go to board two where we've got
stefanona stefanova excuse me versus
pogonina was combining both those words
uh Natalia poganina was a longtime
contributor on chess.com for many years
for those OG's of our platform can go
back and check out some of her articles
from years ago uh pogonino's work was
was always amazing uh here she has the
black pieces against stefanova they drew
the first game so this matches is um as
anyone's anyone's to take right now
neither player is in a muslin situation
okay
and
well it feels like a very unusual start
so White Knight on E2 Queen on D3 is not
very often to see in this type of games
right normally we can assume like Scotch
where you got the Knight of D4 and maybe
Queen on D2 Bishop on E3 then you do F3
G forward here it's different but on the
other hand black got also spent on
tempos for Bishop V7 okay the bishop f8
I think the key Point here is
weather-wide is on time to push G1 right
onto G5 and then trying to start with
the King side attack quickly and for
black the main things whether he can do
D5 or b5b for on time before your pieces
were kind of kicked back yeah it's it's
what was the opening of this looks like
uh I mean we get positions almost like
this in some lines of the Petrov but
this is
okay so it actually was a Petra oh no it
wasn't it was Knight C3 sorry
I see this is not
not your standard opening every day and
uh breaking some principles for
beginners there bringing the queen out
early
um but uh
show them the front yes the final is not
the E4 player at all I'm not sure for
her reason Supply but in general or not
right interesting so not only not
necessarily an E4 player but playing the
uh the funk beer as our Eco says with
this D4 let's just say it's not your
most traditional Road traveled and
I kind of I kind of like black setup
just from what you said G4 doesn't seem
easy to get
um although okay what did you just play
what if you just play H3
yeah
so how about B5 here okay go for it Zach
the pawn
it takes them Bishop D7 I love that
Here Comes Rook to be a E4 is also Under
Fire
um right now with the queen having moved
it's going to be it's going to be a wild
one for sure pogonina is a dragon player
as black I can say that so she might not
mind a position like this where she's
sacrificed upon and and uh gonna be all
in with with an attack so
this could be this could be a sharp one
we'll see we'll see how it develops and
come back to it
um a lot of other games rolling I'm
gonna I'm gonna jump ahead to uh
the game between Yip and zuckneezy uh
need z
[Music]
um
situation
sorry what I mean Nana is in your
mastering situation yep and and with the
black pieces although
this might be all that she could ask for
what a sharp position sometimes
sometimes when you see people go all in
with these kind of crazy lines and and
they're the ones who only need a draw
you get a little skeptical in terms of
the approach I mean I'm not just saying
that because it looks sharp and maybe
black has a chance to to take E4 but
what are your thoughts on that do you do
you vary your repertoire based I mean I
said earlier how I asked you earlier how
tough it is to be in a muslin situation
when you're the one who's lost but also
what about when you're the one who's won
right if you only need a draw is that
also a psychological trap right do you
want to just play your sharp openings
like Carissa has played here or is that
something you you try to avoid if you
don't have to be um all in for the win
oh wow it depends I think if you think
too much about the resort and the
suddenly become you know like a
different person you started to look for
look crazy look for the drawing line
that might be a bad signal right because
the way you really hope some results
that you found everything are unclear
and you spend a lot of time you play too
passive so the recommendation just be
yourself and doing the normal moves and
when you see some forcing noise go
further I think that's the same and if
you're in a worse situation then you try
to avoid that I guess and for the
position the game we look at I've heard
that Carissa is a tactical player so I
guess yeah I I guess her uh choice is
really making sense because if we sell
any stuff that she should play something
very solid stable especially against the
Sicilian that's hard right and this
position I think it's really double aged
the question is whether that can take on
e4 even though then why it would be
super heavy General F6 controlling D5 I
guess almost winning so the possibility
would be Knight ce4 because otherwise
Bishop D5 but what happens now in ce4
we need some calculation right
yeah it looks
uh so just again to highlight uh what if
I was just saying Knight takes C4 is not
only maybe the best move for black it
may almost be the only move right
because if you're not all in on this any
other move white is white is eliminating
this Knight and then immediately filling
the D5 Square probably with Bishop D5
and it's just fantastic so so I think
more than likely we will see zagnesi
play Knight C takes E4 as kind of the
only move note that note that Knight
takes E4 runs into Bishop D5 right away
and there is no Intermezzo attacking the
queen because white takes with check
um
so Knight C takes E4 is probably the
only move and then the question is what
does Carissa play here
six
and then Knight C3 sorry I missed that
no 9c3 right that might be an
interesting line 95 Queen H1 King D2 so
wait in which one
Bishop F6 93 then Knight E5 oh I have no
idea but just the same point there's
Bishop S7 Checkmate but I guess oh my
gosh that is amazing just I gotta show
the line with Knight takes E2 and then
you see the everyone's favorite moment
where the evil bar jumps up the board
night night
yeah I was calculating 94 then Queen
takes E4 so wow crazy but there's like
what is going on here Rook takes H2 and
King C3
well until let's see you have their okay
sorry check at the list
that's a Perpetual yeah like all like
all exciting games it might end in a
draw oh no wait Knight F3 check oh wow
just just block it might have three okay
what a crazy move
yeah uh but okay but hold on where did
this line so it started here with Knight
C3 95 Queen H1 King D2
what
this is such a scary position what a CR
I mean and again sometimes you can't
always trust the eval bar first year
remember it's designed to help peep
sometimes the game in check it spots
blunders quickly but sometimes the depth
doesn't always pick up on a sacrifice or
something that might take a minute so I
don't think it's a waste of time that
we're looking at this even though maybe
black should be winning
maybe there's some simple move here
yeah I bullied with the Holy miss
something but agree that we're not here
to study this position
funny to suddenly see this 195 but at
first I saw nicely
I love that 94 can be met by Queen E4
again Bishop seven Checkmate but maybe
black has some like like what is
actually happening if you just take the
bishop like what is the what is the win
because you can't move the Knight the
Queen the queen gets taked
foreign
okay nothing
black is winning conclusion
conclusion conclude your Black is Black
is winning
um okay well it looks like she has taken
E4 just before I put my foot in my mouth
as I normally do want to make sure I'm
at the Y position indeed I am so it's
like nizi has actually taken this is
this is the live board and Carissa is on
the clock
um so Knight takes Bishop takes F6 and
Knight takes E5 crazy idea but
conclusion black is winning
um
so maybe I should try Knight take C4
Knight takes E4 and Miss Black just
heading to the end game I mean black is
up what two two points here
or I guess just one pawn it feels oh
yeah the F5 might lose in the future
yeah so kind of like it kind of feels
like two pawns block is up
okay well again if you're just tuning in
checking in on this sharp situations
agnesia as we said lost the first game
to the young American and so uh black
has to win this game but that was our
dialogue as uh maybe this is a game that
you're happy to have just because
um
um it's gonna be Sharp
question here Bishop A4 B5 Knight B5
they've actually they've actually played
that
yeah I mean is there is there Knight
takes B5 here I mean yeah what happens
if Knight V5
what is the move here
King the yeah maybe you have to play
Kingda
yeah because 96 96
well the moves are coming
Knight takes D6 if Queen takes D6 Rook
to D1
yeah it's winning
what we missed maybe bishop D7 instead
of King D okay yeah yeah that actually
makes sense because now with Knight C3
probably you just take first so
no but 19393 Bishop C6 then takes on A8
ah yeah yeah okay yeah so white wins
material there so if Knight to C3 you
just have to move the queen 27 or yeah
and it takes you're taking one thing but
okay you can you can play this way I
guess because you won
you've won a bunch of Pawns so wow all
right well um
okay this is on the board Knight takes
B5 has been played so uh saganizi is
gonna have to figure this out
we'll check in with one more here before
we hop back over to the open section uh
4-4 is danielian versus suduka Sova
[Music]
um
the the first game was drawn uh so game
one of round three between these two
ladies was drawn so
um neither player in a muslin situation
yeah this is like typical uh let's say
Knight f3d5 structure right
um yeah
yeah with the bishop of five line E4
played
um yeah white White's a teeny bit better
but uh Sudoku Silva has got to solve
this problem right now
yeah C3 something like
yeah
okay
in the camera we have the game of
national versus
manga tour right we probably missed that
one that should be on board too
which one was that
um
knock knock versus the manga tool
forward to it yes
trying to find I've got Collision Sky
versus
um
one thing you must win situation but uh
yeah I think white got some strategy
trying some
unusual setups for real game but we'll
see what happens next
okay all right well
lots of games still going I don't think
we've had any results in the books so
for those of you jumping on late good
for you we still have a lot of Chess
ahead and we're gonna we're gonna pop
back over to the open section uh real
quick we see right where we left off on
uh the top board Magnus Carlson
just plays Bishop E7 and uh
audience seems to have dealt with the
with the worst set of Tempe and rather
than Magnus playing Knight D7 he decides
to just settle on developing the bishop
Knight D7 was one of her ideas to bring
the Knight to C5 that we were looking at
with A4 but now after Bishop E7
ariane's move and
how do you handle this do you go in for
your English attack or maybe you move
the Knight try to offer a Queen's Right
another positional idea you highlighted
that earlier uh in the show that Knight
A4 and C4 is is a very common kind of
positional way to squeeze the queen side
on the white side of these time on arms
especially now that E4 is protected but
what are your thoughts on how Ariana
should play this quickly before we find
another one well I think it's unlikely
to happen here because the plan is ready
for D5 if you play A4 maybe he'll push
immediately so make sure that you you
get the full control not like allowing
the uh breakthrough it's possible but I
don't think it really suits the current
situation where white needs a win
because even if you enter into the end
game you play C4 successfully
it still looks equal but
black could even play some G5 then
Knight D7
then maintaining the center
yeah it makes sense
um
we've actually had another couple moves
played quickly already we have
[Music]
um
oh actually it looks like the the live
position was
was updated here we had a we had a small
relay air so it looks like after A5 King
B1 Rook B8 was played first and that was
the movie when I were talking about it
was funny we came back and that was a
little odd so so it was the idea we were
looking at but rather than Knight D7
Queen to B4 was played
I kind of like the Knight D7 idea but
like you said white is in a tough spot
because even if you get Knight A4 and C4
while that is a grip it's not exactly a
position that aryantari can play for a
win and remember Magnus won game one so
yeah
okay
um where to go from here
um
games that we haven't seen so far
there's a lot of excellent games we
haven't seen so far right
um yeah
I just brought up the game here between
Matt lakov and witoshik
because I saw there was a rook on C7 and
I thought it was hanging and then I
realized that white is currently upper
Brook so I know that must have been
traded
yeah it's um probably just took a rook
there yeah indeed all right so I spied
the position it was like why is there a
rook hanging on C7 but there we go it's
roughly equal uh White having a small
edge with this nice this nice centered
knife in the middle of the board
but D4 is a weakness so we'll see why
it's probably hoping for
filter F5 like Bishop
H3 or D3 F5 but black can simply play G6
yeah simple complex should be okay
which is
which is reasonable for both players
again we've been looking at a lot of
games with must win scenarios this is
one of the few uh in the open section
we've checked on uh this morning where a
draw just heads to tie breaks neither
player won game one
so Matt lakov okay with the white pieces
did you maybe just squeeze a small Edge
if he gets something then great if not
then they'll head to tie breaks not sure
not sure which of these two would be the
better in the rapid time controls but
maybe we'll find out
yeah we'll see
uh let's look at Daniel dubov's games uh
game sorry
um
haven't looked at him today he did win
his his first game so uh Malikov is in a
must-win situation with the white pieces
and uh
dubov is on the clock after A5
oh nice Thief
the nail looks so young still I feel
like every time I see him he still looks
12 and I mean that as a compliment he
just doesn't look like he's getting any
older and
that's the ice back to the point to
approach the game I was expecting
something related yes and subtly then
you said okay he looks so yeah but yeah
when looking at the camera yeah agree
he does he just and he's kind of like
his body language too is just sort of uh
I don't know he just looks he just looks
like maybe that's maybe it pays to be
Magnus Carlson's second you get to tap
into the Fountain of Youth and stay
young forever so
wow but he's like 20 something right
yeah he is I don't know I don't know his
age off the top of my head but he's
he's a he is not 12. I can confirm
okay clear
um oh okay after A5 it seems like uh
maybe let's see four
wait that's when I see what I feel like
black should be at least okay yeah
unless if so the whole point here is it
looks like the dynamic is whether the B
Pawn
is is gonna fall but the problem like 95
if you if you play E4 well now you're
self-pinning your own Knight and then D4
is likely a Target so regardless of
where this Knight moves even though
yeah yeah so B5 foreign
yeah I mean Black is Black is able to
trade and take there's Knight to B5 as
you just said so
it's Knight G5 kind of seems like a
no-brainer unless Daniel is
is going to go for Knight C4 but
what other move could he be considering
if not just Knight T5
well Knight C4 also looks possible
because if you go Bishop B4 maybe I'll
exchange on X3 then take on default
trying to capture the B
tour was very tricky
yeah the only other ideas if you could
take and take right away but that you
know I don't no other candy but it seems
like Knight D5 and Knight C4 just makes
sense so I am pointing out a good thing
so how about Bishop F3 then Queen D4
here and you lose B6 ah you take A1 in
windy two I see okay so I inadvertently
pointed that out but this this would be
fantastic uh for Duba because because
it's an opposite code Bishop ending
where even if you don't win you can't
lose this position as black mm-hmm
so maybe bishop F3 Queen D4 yeah maybe
that's what he's thinking about ready
for all the way yeah yeah
well we're being told by chat we should
go oop sorry about that opened up a uh a
new tab that was in accident and I want
to go check out
um prague's game because he is
he is maybe moving toward a win from
what chat has said and with with doing
so he would be
punching his ticket
into round four what a
what a hot start for this young man and
uh
he's he could be he doesn't even need to
win for those keeping track he already
won game one so a draw is good enough to
go to round four but
uh prognananda wants the whole thing
yeah I mean no no he wants to win
because the whites
referred and trying to find
and already things went wrong because
the drawer or I mean lose doesn't really
matter is the full possible right so so
this is keep fighting hoping for some
chances because he call this H4
so but it's very hard
to provide we left this board as you
said right right here after after
Whitehead had taken on h8 and King D7
and the lines we were looking at were as
Evon was just saying it it was likely
was just meant to be a draw but
um the point is a draw is just as good
as a loss so instead in this position
Bishop E2 and gives up the bishop a
check and the pawn with check
um and uh
and yeah he gets himself a little bit of
trouble apparently queen of four was
maybe no good knight to D5
it's not so simple I mean black has a
lot of pressure and I guess the B Pawn
is running but
what exactly is Black's threat if white
thinks he can you know run the H Pawn
what is the next move
well I was even thinking someone for
like King B6 Knight B4 Bishop
b793 because of this ping
um
I was thinking H4 is kind of Dual
Purpose because it also prepares Rook H3
which is a defensive
but maybe it can be six eight four ninth
B for just on time
uh night before right away and you're
yeah being made to C2 or Bishop B7
actually maybe
or Knight to D3 check you're actually
threatening all of it
though black is material dumb but not I
guess annoyed would be more valuable
compared to the local H1 so actually
black is nothing worried that is he's
selling material but just plays on
normal moves and make use of the
king and the Beverly Place the pieces of
White's position
well as you can see in the live board uh
directly next to ephon and myself that
the black is not moved yet we're just
looking at a line here but
but yeah I think I think King to B6 your
suggestion makes the most sense the only
other thing is what I was first
mentioning is like does black just
calculate and try to push the people on
it
no no you go ahead
yeah if you push Beholder you got H4
okay just three like then your idea and
the probably why it could create some
chaotic positions yeah some defensive
okay yeah I agree no B4 seems slow so
King to B6 H4 Knight to B4 let's say
Rook H3
do you do you play Knight D3 check is
that the idea and I guess so you're just
winning and I would have to sacrifice
then CD3 and then like okay if I push
you up Knight C2 and it's just over
yeah
so white white is in trouble in all
these lines and Prague is
Prague is uh looking like he's gonna be
heading into round four
um
someone who may not be headed into round
four is Mama jarov let's actually take a
quick peek at that
um he lost
he lost the first game to to the young
man from Armenia hike Modi rosian
um currently playing in the junior
speeches Championship but but okay this
position this could be one of those
sneaky positions where we don't think
mamad yarov has many winning chances for
most the game but a patient approach for
white you know white white does have a
long-term pool and and now even the A3
Pawn might be a Target there like to
some to some plans right
yeah maybe bishop do you want uh yeah
you could even move the rock yeah very
good
okay
um
yeah some trousers
all right well I've been told by my
producer it's either time to take a
quick break or for me to start break
dancing and so I think for most of the
fans they would choose a break rather
than a break dance and so we're gonna
take a very quick breather uh don't go
anywhere we got about 10 000 of you with
us on Twitch 2500 on YouTube and a few
people wondering where mixer went we'll
be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ly playing some uh Maybe not maybe not
as equally accurate chess but equally as
exciting are the members uh competing in
tournament Arc too we've got those very
very well known to uh the the anime
Community going up against a whole bunch
of people from the fighting game
Community part of the fun bringing these
non-traditional chess audiences to uh to
really enjoy the game and uh the show
there has been has been really awesome
so for those who want to tune in to an
afternoon show obviously this is very
early for those on the west coast with
me
um make sure you uh you check out
tournament Arc running right now where
we're three days in so uh so check it
out all right speaking of checking out
the games we've got
um right now the the game between Ariana
and Magnus Carlson is maybe heading down
that road we predicted 984 was played if
on
but I feel like that's getting closer in
fact now the Queens are off the board he
plays it before I can say it it's
getting closer to the end game where
probably white just can't win uh this
kind of position
yeah she takes F6 I mean it's unlikely
to think that white will be here even
you know some people may prefer to play
with black pieces as the whole Mobility
to develop and for why it's you know
developing ideas he could do apart from
C4 because if you want to go some night
manure 90 to night C4 will face D5
immediately so maybe you still need to
place in four right
but you know and these positions are
always instructive for for players who
don't play the Sicilians sometimes you
look at this and think black just has to
be worse while while the structural uh
deficiencies are real the bishop pair is
just so strong long term for black is
you see these positions in all kinds of
classical Sicilians you have an Indian
Sicilians and if black can play for both
F5 and D5 the position will eventually
become Dynamic and and the Bishops will
come to life uh particularly this uh
this dark Square Bishop over here that's
the white lacks so
um all right gonna be a tough one
unfortunately for for the young Carissa
Yip I'm gonna I'm gonna go back over to
uh the women's section because we left
it in a really exciting moment after
Knight takes B5 had been played uh
zagnesi did Play Bishop D7 if on but
Carissa responded with the move Knight
takes these Knight takes D6 instead of
Knight to C3 or even uh well I guess 93
was the main move we were looking at
instead she played the move Knight takes
D6 and
[Music]
um
excuse me trying to trying to get back
to that line here she played the move
Knight takes D6 and has now gotten
herself in trouble after Queen takes D6
Bishop takes Queen takes it looks like
white is just down a piece
yeah I mean sometimes why sacrifice is
your King on b1.com D1 then you try to
give pressure on both d and e open files
but now it's not the case yet the wine
skin is still in the middle of nowhere
so it's hard to expect that there will
be any real attacks against Black's King
well she played Bishop takes F6 which
zag means he's on the clock is going to
have to take with the Knight
um taken with the pawn and white will
win back the piece so is there is there
some outside chances here with I mean
Knight takes and fives or something
Carissa has here
yeah but maybe Queen beef five
yeah Queen DB5 is a
great move
yeah otherwise if you go B7 they can she
can do long castle and if you go E7 the
same thing so
yeah this is a good move because it
offers the queen trade so
there may not be any Knight C4 is a
discovered check but then the king can
move and
it doesn't just doesn't seem like
White's going to have enough I mean it's
a practical game in the sense that you
know there's always a chance to blunder
when your king is in the middle of the
board but for players of this level
probably black is is just going to
convert the extra piece
yeah the next few moves will be decisive
if black successfully move the king to
the safer area then the game is almost
over because right I mean now I still
like feel moves away from that point so
we'll see
okay well let's um let's head back over
to the to the open section um we just
wanted to check on that because we had
been diving into the tactics there
um
okay tari has played the move G4 which
which makes a lot of sense trying to
keep the king side crippled your best
chance of winning is a long-term
positional grind if you're if you're
white uh I want to head over to Essa
panko's game though it was a game that
was
um super spicy and exciting when it
first meets the eye
um we ended up diving in and seeing it
was it was actually very much theory for
a long time let's let's give everyone a
quick recap because all the way to this
position here
um on move 16. we were still in theory
essapenko played the move H4 which was
the first novelty
um
on the board and
Queen to B6 was played trying to get C5
discovered check
Queen A3 C5 check King G3
castles and now the move Rook to D1 you
highlighted that you know one of the
things about this position is when you
look at this you see White's King in the
center but all the long-term features
favor white right as long as white can
solve the King You've Got the D7 Pawn
that's weak you've got the D6 Square
this week and that's kind of where the
game heads with white getting the Rook
on D1
um
starting to starting to maybe favor
white a little bit right
yeah I think in general it's very hard
to play with black pieces
yeah Bishop E2 is played makes you
wonder can black somehow
rake open the position with D5 or
anything to change the structure but
yeah but then you're not on time if you
can exchange and bring the line to D4
yeah it'll be you know be comfortable
but not not this position because then
exchange of D1 maybe already 93 first uh
uh yeah oh Queen three just too many
weakness before your pieces go into the
right place right
yeah okay so so instead Rook to be eight
played poking at B2 Rook D2 to respond
here comes the Knight to the D4 Square
as you said
but then Rook to D6
and after Queen B4
what is going on here
I'm not so sure I mean I guess white is
just going to be better in all these
transitions because of the week D7 pawn
and the D6 Square so it feels like
abasov has just lost any chances right
and in the sense that what a weird line
with the King to run here but white has
this uh this end game in mind and the
King on G3 doesn't look so bad anymore
with the Queens coming off the board
mm-hmm
Bishop D1 Bishop B4 B4 and now King to
f8 and I believe we have caught up with
the live position
even even B takes c ah then Knight can
be three okay
seems like wine has multi options
even
be five the B5 or B6 that's not good yep
Bishop A4 key seven
yeah Bishop A4 candy E7 guards the pawn
but okay so
oh no there's 92 sorry oh 92. okay
a morning a morning for me uh late late
evening for you wake up call right don't
miss the fork
Rook to C3 and so what's the deal with
black takes the pawn here there's okay
yeah the night the night falls so so
taking once is fine but now you'd have
to deal with the Knight and and taking
is instantly regrettable so
so yeah it's just hard for black and I I
guess that means this is a clear threat
right because taking undermines the
protection of the night and and Black's
only Advantage is disappearing
yeah
that's the panko
looking like he might be in a good spot
to move on I posed the question earlier
who will be the youngest who will be the
youngest competitor left at some point
um
you still have uh progdananda who I
believe is right there asapenko one of
the other very young participants made a
name for himself earlier this year
beating Magnus Carlson and Todd of
Steele
um exciting to see how how are these
young players can go in events like this
yeah duffel
so maybe we'll look at some yeah any
other games to shout out games we
haven't looked so far because I feel
like they're still some games that we
haven't checked yet for sure for sure
um
and if if you want to yell at anyone we
can
um Etienne bakrow is playing the good
doctor as I like to call him
assemba mean um neither player in a
must-win scenario here uh and the the
eval bar also reflecting what looks to
be a virtual coin flip
um Bishop versus knight battle shouse
commence
who do you who do you like instinctively
you're not you're not allowed to use
your super Grand Master brain just when
you first look at the board who do you
like white or black like flash card
chests we're gonna play flash card chess
I'm gonna show you a position and you
just have to say who's better
it's against your instincts to not use
your analytical brain but um
I instantly look at this and I kind of
like white just because I don't see any
Targets for black on the light squares
but then of course the light squares
themselves might be a bit of a problem
for the white king but I feel like white
can maneuver in a way that maybe black
can't but maybe I'm just wrong
yeah at first I saw black probably
because you know got this fascinating
long diagonals um
G1 but second is great uh scrubs are
like white because you got the light on
D for all the dark Square Palms but
maybe you want is better because you got
the chance to play F3 but after F3
Bishop F3 because in The Rook end game
White Spot would become weakness so
white needs to maintain D4 right
therefore maybe this game will just
ended in this kind of symmetrical ways
like nobody really changes the position
but maybe you can just you know who's
moving up by the way black right so
maybe
black no Bishop D5
some move like that
yeah it makes sense because if you let
white do the plan you're talking about
rookie three rookie one
maybe then even like an H4 at some point
the king can come up your move F3 is is
on the agenda if the bishop is pinned so
I get if white got rookie three rookie
one then F3 is a threat in some
positions because the bishop can't take
it
um
I don't know I just I I feel like the
long-term maneuvering Edge would favor
white but like you said as long as black
maintains the diagonal
not really anything you can do there's
too many potential problems so all right
flash card just continues we're gonna go
to uh to my boy Jordan Von fur East
just first instinct who's better
oh I just saw the position
here
why
Casper boreon um polish Grandmaster
versus Jordan Von for East and uh you
like white even though we've got the
weak E3 Pawn
uh yeah because we got the bishop on D5
we got openc file that potentially could
go to roxy7 so I don't think white will
be worse but the question is is he
really better
okay
I like this flash card chest this is fun
flashcard chess okay we're gonna go to
uh one of the one of the stars of the
events so far another young Superstar
from Uzbekistan sundarov who sent
alireza faruja home
um earlier uh in the event I guess last
round and of course Ali Reza is a
superstar with a huge fan base and all
the online uh Blitz and bullets
streaming communities unfortunately Mr
farugia is no longer dancing in Sochi so
if you didn't get that memo sindarov who
we're now looking at is taking on Jorge
Corey
um and flashcard chess who's better here
white this is clear okay this one's
clear tell us tell us why
uh
well let me think well maybe I'm
sorry I didn't be concrete but this is
like white is but look at the pieces and
the diagonals a to G8 d3h7 is Queen of
these lots of bad maybe white gold Queen
E2 here in the meantime oh wow that's a
move there you go that might be why
White's better in fact the engine agrees
with you I didn't I was looking at the
email bar honestly and I was like why is
white better here because Black's up the
pawn
but this is a very strong move because
how do you stop Bishop C4 check
I mean
yeah
Knight F6 right
oh very nice and then maybe you can take
here and win the queen
yeah I give I give two minor pieces I
thought I'd give only one so maybe not
much
so maybe if Queen E2 Bishop E6 you don't
need to sacrifice you can actually just
put the bishop to safety and then you're
threatening some things maybe
so this is why I when I first looked I
was like what why is white just better
here there must be some move in this
position
but just it feels like there are
different tries but okay let's think
concrete
a funny move how about the bishop a six
or maybe bishop B5 just to traps a coin
oh wow Bishop B5 actually takes A4
like meaning meaning this move actually
literally okay that's the move computer
agrees because this is
the queen okay um
that's a very nice move yeah the the
bishop on on D5 traps the the queen
because of A4
so takes takes Bishop takes and this is
actually kind of interesting right it's
not I mean just just saying like this
isn't like over yet necessarily even
though White's better
um yeah nothing entirely because it got
96 or C8
yeah and you could even play Bishop C4
first and anyway but obviously that's
definitely better for white soap okay
so it is indorev's uh sundarov's play
the uh by the way in the camera we got
the resort on the board 17 is it 17.
looks like it is who is who is on board
17. I have no idea a lot most players
are not
I'm scrolling down to see if I see a oh
we got it it's fedocia versus goreev so
fedesev who won in game one of round
three
against timorgarayev looks like gets
gets a quick draw here quick relatively
speaking we're about
we're about two hours into the round so
um perusev will be going on to round
four
obviously we're big big fans of uh the
big fish on chess.com the big fish 1995
is his username I speak in usernames on
chess.com so he's and he's very
underrated uh Blitz and bullet player um
Gabe Nakamura run for his money in the
last speed Chess Championship so so fedo
save will be playing in round four
congratulations to the first person to
punch their ticket
[Music]
um
sorry go ahead oh sorry I'll just say
that feather said he's a very good
bullets on bullet player because I just
remember that we played a friendly match
and the his blizz is just like super
fast because we played both rapidly
blades and luckily I think I got some
plus score in the rapid but suddenly in
Blitz he was just like crushing most of
the games I I mean so that shows his
real strengths yep we're gonna check in
on Nihao Soren's game we uh I saw him in
the background there somewhere I feel
like if you peered your eyes there you
could see the young the young man from
India who has his work cut out for him
he lost the first game to Dimitri on
draken uh we now have the second game
pulled up where uh
yeah it's a rook ending where
to be honest probably only white has
very very minor winning chances just
because of the the slight advantage that
is the two on one versus the the four on
three but I think it's more than likely
that nihao's World Cup run is going to
come to an end here in round three
is that him in the background there I
think you can see Nelson there in the
background
uh
I cannot see clearly Maybe
yeah this position will I think will be
draw very soon
yeah this is gonna be gonna be a draw so
unfortunately for those um for those
knee-how fans
um we know many on YouTube we see you
over there
I don't think it's gonna I don't think
that it's gonna continue
for Mr Soren after this event the battle
between two uh two players from India we
also looked at earlier Vida Gujarati
versus
adibon bhaskaran
back to this one here uh flash guard
chess continues who's better refund
white white okay
and why is that
um well different coloration we know
there might be potential attacking
chances it just feels like this bishop
on D3 could be the hope of the game but
uh yeah it depends on whether black is
on time to push Rook C1 at a fight me
for it if it's not
then white goes on Queen C2 you know
maybe one could be sorry oh wait why
this upon down I just realized that well
maybe not that important but or
it's one of those funny positions where
if you could put the queen on F5 or
something white is like
extremely better right because the the
nature of these obstacles Bishop battles
are that whoever gets pressure on their
color complex first is is really in
control over the initiative but
so the the Strategic factors in the
position are not as relevant as the
dynamic factors because the queen is not
where she needs to be if you could put
the queen on H5 or G4 or F5 then you
really like White's position right but
you can't quite do that
yeah but it's still because white got
time
if we can stop at five before we can
slowly manure because black space job is
really badly placed I think black will
be fine if you do not have the default
Pawn because that Bishop could go to D4
probably that would be less problem but
now this bishop is inactive so that's
the reason why I said the first time
maybe white is pretty happy to get this
position I like it
sorry go ahead I was gonna say I love
when the flash card chest disagrees with
the computer engine because you really
do like white and I agree with you
because dynamically black is up a pawn
but that material not really as relevant
as as where this could go on the light
Square so sorry what were you going to
say
so I just said maybe black got some E4
D3 idea
not sure if that would be real again
this position but I was just trying to
activate this bishop on B6
yeah it is black to play so you said F5
I I can't play this obviously because
the trade and then you win the pawn but
yeah you'll see one first I was trying
to mention yeah like Rook C1 takes and
then F5 which just seems crazy
But Here Comes E4
yeah
I was I was apparently wrong because
quickly to say that uh well I was
correct that uh the first person to move
on to the next round is indeed Vladimir
fetto save but there is another game in
the books and that is between Anish Fury
and abdusa turov they drew quickly here
um in that French game
um that we that we looked at very early
on in our coverage if you missed it so
uh they will be playing tie breaks um if
you're if you're tuning in neither
player neither player was on the line in
this round so look for a tie Break
battle between Anish giri and Abdul
satoroff to take place tomorrow that'll
be interesting
um
okay another game we haven't looked at
yet at all is Samuel sevion the American
versus the top player from Poland Jan
Christophe Duda
taking a look at this one
neither player is uh is is fighting for
their life necessarily but it does look
like uh John Kristoff has an advantage
yeah some typical
safety for uh
end game
black Gods this C5 and double f pole but
on the other hand the White's Acer and
the B3 also weakened
yep well it's accurate to play Black
could survive here but yeah a bit
careful
so what are the day what are the pieces
you want here I mean if you're the
bishop trade is being offered
but I would think the bishop trade
probably favors white just because it
makes it easier to use this square and
slowly maneuver but maybe not if it
brings The Rook into a position where
these pawns are being targeted is that
that's kind of black saying okay even if
you want to trade the Bishops you have
to improve my rook in the process
yeah agree I think to trade off the
bishop is trying to give the A6 Square
for the rock as as we mentioned before a
A3 and B3 Pawn should be the target for
black trying to balance the position
right because then let's see tonight was
kind of restricted here right so that's
the reason for Bishop A6 because you do
not need your Bishop somewhere else if
on the B7 this diagonal y simply can go
F3 things like that and the switch up
will be doing nothing there so it
shouldn't be I mean where is for black
at least
okay
well like you said with best plays Sam
should be fine and and we likely will
have tie breaks um another battle we
checked on earlier was uh Yvonne uh
sheparin off defending defending that
initiative against Peter spidler and it
was fun because earlier in the day when
we first started the first people on
camera were engaging in an awkward
handshake here's a recap of that wait
wait wait wait let's go again let's do
it again like what what
um yep I love okay that's gonna be you
know how many times that has probably
happened around the world in the last
year like that exact moment it's
happened to me more than a few times
where like you go to shake someone's
hand or you like you want to pound it to
avoid the germs and then
what do you think about that no
I never thought about this kind of
question before
anyway so that was a funny moment we
caught on camera and you know I would
bet that that awkward situation The
Awkward the awkward post pandemic
handshake as we'll call it um
all right but this position not so
awkward and given that they drew the
first game I think we might be headed to
tie breaks uh Peters Fiddler won the
pawn back but now we're headed for an
equal end game right
yeah castroish
yeah the uh the position we left it on
was right here for those just tuning in
Knight to D5 was played we were having
all kinds of fun talking about
checkmates on the diagonal but black
would have been able to defend
so instead
um instead Knight to D5 was played and
after the trades white wins the pawn
back
but uh
but doesn't have an initiative any
longer so
okay so many other games still going
um we haven't looked at Alexei shirov's
game we haven't looked at Sam shanklin's
game versus arashenko
um karyakan and Gregorio porn a lot of
games that we have not tuned into yet uh
up ahead when we come back and of course
we'll stay tuned to the uh the top games
we've been following from the start so
chess.com's coverage of the feed a World
Cup here with women's world champion
hoey Fawn continues and just a few
moments don't go anywhere
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
World Cup rolling we will be rolling
into pogchamps four that's right get
hyped it was announced the dates will be
August 29th through September 12th with
our presenting sponsor coinbase Ludwig
will be back Mr Beast will be back some
other brand new faces and it's going to
be super pumped I guess I just revealed
a couple of the players but we've got
more on that coming soon of course all
your all your favorite commentators and
coaches it's going to be going to be
epic POG champ style mark your calendars
for now let's uh
let's get back into this one we see that
Magnus is not only defending just fine
but also maybe getting in a position
that's going to be a a slight Edge right
here pretty soon G4 was played uh with
where we left it and then D5 is you kind
of highlighted that if you don't play C4
D5 might be the response and Magnus
heard you he agrees and now with H5 and
the huge trade this feels like black is
the only one who can probably win with
these weaknesses that are that are
appearing in White's camp
yeah black color got the bishop on E7
that completely keep this Knight on A4
out doing nothing right and then we can
attack the isolated pumps on each one
Chief when also the super Bishop just
blocks the squares that the dragon D5
might enter in
so if black doing nothing here it will
be a drawer and if black is ambitious he
could hope for a little bit more than
that yep
well quickly to flash other positions uh
Daniel dubov did did
um draw his game when we left it the
trade
um well actually let's see here is that
where they actually just agreed to the
draw no okay so we had
Queen takes D4 then E3 rather than
taking b6 you and I had looked at the
line with takes B6
but
there's something wrong Knight still on
F3 yeah yeah okay yeah something was
wrong Bishop takes F3 was played before
Queen takes D4 yeah
um after A5 Bishop takes F3 takes and
then the line we talked about uh with E3
and queen takes B2
um okay so this one ended a draw I'm
gonna quickly just kind of scroll
through any of the other positions that
that we have going
um we already said Anish giri and Abdul
saturov Federal save is moving on
we uh
as I said before we left we haven't
looked at carjakan's game with apari
Gregorian but
um no need to because it went ending in
the drawing kariakin is moving on to
round four
where else are we at players
we haven't checked looking at Sam
shanklin's game versus arashenko
I call that ax
for Queen D7
um okay
yeah this looks
this looks good for white although black
is starting to win the pawn back on D4
right so
maybe bishop D3
because if you go Queen D7 we might have
Bishop E4 and trying to capture the pawn
G5 I see I see because it takes takes
and Rook D6 just to show efon's line
Queen takes G5 looks
looks pretty good
but I might miss the Knight D4 instead
of rock D6
yeah after the 4fe 490 or even 90 D4
here yeah yeah
okay
well
um
yeah maybe bishop C4 here why should
this
somehow better oh in the camera we saw
but what happened over there which which
game is this one we have that we have
liftoff I have no idea the knife no it's
cool I think that was Nihao Sauron maybe
oh yeah it's me how
has drawn his game and unfortunately
that means that uh one of the top
players from India will be headed home
um
the the young man lost his first game to
Dimitri on draken and so with that draw
the Hal Sauron is uh no longer dancing
in Sochi
what does the red dot mean does that
mean you're eliminated
red doc they put like a red dot on uh
mihao sauron's
name badge there
it was interesting I don't know
in the camera always so
it was walking maybe we should check his
game we haven't yeah yeah that's another
game we haven't looked at good call
go to take a look at at Alexander
grishek's game we will uh find it first
game so I guess today it wouldn't be a
very hard day for him
yeah he does have the black pieces but
because he won the first game it's it's
put Alan uh show in in a tough spot
yeah it's still like early middle game
but both players spend to love time it's
grishek so the uh he's the the punch
line of time pressure right
but here just one interesting move how
about I mean it wouldn't work but how
about G4
uh okay so the the Red Dot means they're
not allowed and allowed back in the
playing hole anymore which is
which is I'm curious is that because
Nihao was eliminated or just is it
something they do after every game just
because they want to clear the players
out I think both would be reasonable
right
um yeah so good good to know there
um
fun fun info and thank you for that
yeah by the way this position got an
interesting line if G4 Bishop
d735 Bishop C6
oh yeah that's a that's a wait that's a
that's a piece let's look at that G4
Bishop D7 G5
the bishop is trapped
yeah maybe C6
it doesn't work for a while
F6
yeah that's a good find though G4 G5 is
is sort of tricky and hanging in the air
but yeah would would apparently be much
worse for white than it is for black
because of this Knight problem on F3
yeah still too early to uh expect the
resort of this game
but mostly likely because chocolate will
be fine yeah
yeah and grishek is
totally totally used to time pressure
how do you feel you handled time
pressure is it is it something that uh
you struggled with
playing or are you are you someone who
made made efforts to always be up on the
clock
uh no no no I didn't make I didn't make
any special efforts on the time
management so I just thought it mainly
depends on the game situation depends on
the process uh but in general I mean I'm
definitely not as good as Chris yoga who
manage time pressure that well but
normally it is okay I mean just not like
for example 10 move 10 moves no 10
minutes play for 20 or 30 moves I guess
that's not the case apart from that this
will be all right
yeah okay makes sense and obviously yeah
every game different but we know that
grishek who yes is a three-time World
list Champion is is uh almost seems to
be inviting time pressure in a lot of
his games
um
we see we have we've had us Fiddler and
uh ship Arena on camera more than a few
times we'll go ahead and flip back to
the game although
as we said it seems like the most
exciting moments of that particular
battle
um
happened just after the awkward
handshake
um but uh
but okay
um but they're playing an end game
they're playing a rook ending
likely headed to tie breaks are these
two because they drew their first game
oh in the camera we have another game
finished
let me go back to that
asapenko wins yeah and so we were we
were talking about this one wow what a
what an impressive game for sopenko who
will be moving on to round four with
that result let's back up and see what
happened if on because we left the
position after B4
um the Knight being undermined King to
f8 was followed by Rook to C3
and I guess black didn't know what to do
he played King E7 and allowed B takes C5
but we were saying here like what other
moves are there there's
capturing didn't help white would simply
recapture
um and then and then the Knight is
hanging
B takes C5 Knight C6 and then the trade
on e4 followed by gobbling up that E
Pawn
and uh avasoff just had no answer
a lot of Pawns
yeah
Oh What A Move by the way this move
Bishop to C2
typical level two cut off the light
great move cutting off the Rooks
protection of the night the night is not
often you see a knight trapped on D2 an
enemy Knight trapped on D2 and was that
it the bishop C2 and he just resigned
yeah
I guess the threat is
you sorry what uh just no point to
continue I mean there are too many ways
to win this okay yeah I guess the threat
is also C6 and Rook takes A7 or or Rook
takes A7 and then C6 as well just too
many too many things happening if Knight
to be one I guess white just trades it
forget trapping it and takes A7 and the
game is just over
yeah there's three extra polls yeah too
many
well this was an exciting one again we
first really joined it all the way back
on King F3 but uh for those who are uh
time on off players this was all Theory
and asapenko knew exactly what he was
doing with the novelty of H4
and went on to uh to win a very very
clean game here in this round
a positional master master class by Essa
panko
as my as my uh my my buddy just texted
me yeah it's a great game
um all right well where else do we want
to go
some new games
for maybe for
so we can check the Magnus we checked
Fabiano we checked uh wait let me check
Fabiano went in a while
oh yeah we have a look sure
yeah let me uh let me search his game
also I just realized the less than you
saw is not
um like according to the ratings
yeah
yeah there's a lot of games still going
it'll it'll get easier to follow the
World Cup as we get to the later rounds
but this is so we haven't looked at this
game for some time uh we left it in the
opening and
still still kind of unclear but I
probably am suffering from Fabiano bias
itis here and just that I like White's
position
you like White's position okay Fabiano
bias itis I suffer from it so
ugh
but I mean seems to me white is a little
weird little one weird yeah
yeah this queen like fortnite on G3 when
you already got Black's phone G6 it
seems like all your hobbies against the
C5 Pole
uh
so you're saying that with Black's
position kind of being ideal defensively
these nights are a little bit awkwardly
placed
okay like I said it's probably just
Fabiano bias
um
but
so the D5 pawns a Target the B Pawn is
blockaded by the bishop on B3 but maybe
there's just like a plan like Bishop A6
to C4 maybe I'm just maybe black is
doing totally fine here
yeah Bishop A6 is seems like a good move
because of why something like this
yeah
because the light is not a weight he
played Bishop A6 yeah okay yeah
full camera shot there
Juma bayev on the black side known as
jumbo here on chess.com
versus Fabiano
probably will respond with Rook F2
um
we haven't actually seen Bishop A6 yet
on the board apparently
yeah it is on the board oh there we go
so just small delay we've had Bishop A6
relayed and now we see it
real Capital Bishop C4 well I really got
a bit worried for a wide position
yeah maybe he'll be fun with some look
F2 Bishop C4 B2
oh
no idea
but that drama5f is the kind of down
time right that I guess it's still got
another 10 or 15 moves to go it was a
first time control
okay so maybe we should check some other
games
okay
what other games to go to
we haven't chat we haven't checked
Maxim's day
sorry
oh wait uh Maxim
I think he's saying
well let's just find some games that we
haven't seen so far
okay
um so a number of them we've got Thomas
chefsky's game versus edani
um
this looks strollish yeah which uh
doesn't necessarily do anything for that
match
they both they uh they drew their first
game so
well that's great
oh we'll have an interview we're gonna
have an interview with Sergey kariakin
oh that's one
that was um that was a little a little
surprising there but uh here we go we're
gonna take a very quick break and when
we return we will have an interview with
the uh the former World Championship
Challenger uh back in 2016 and still uh
top player from Russia Sergey kariakin
joins us in just a minute don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
and we are now joined by a grand master
Sergey kariakin who moves on to round
four after defeating Gregorio parin
Sergey congratulations and uh are you
enjoying your time in Sochi so far yes
yes it's a great it's a great place and
I love it very much and I hope to stay
here as long as possible you want to be
there as long as possible that makes
sense so as a guy who's played in both
World Championship matches and uh World
Cup Championship events which one do you
enjoy more
foreign
well I I liked very much in Baku in
World Cup
2015. it was great Island and good
results
the uh
do you do you want to take us through
any of the critical moments of your
match with with uh oparan We've um well
uh things that today's game wasn't so so
much interesting I managed to uh to hold
without
anything special but yesterday it was
quite
oh it's interesting
yeah I've uh
I've got that game pulled up and we can
we can jump to a critical moment here
and uh yeah so so I think that I
suppressed him in the opening he didn't
expect my
um A5 after Bishop before uh
and okay well so later on he sacrificed
upon and it was very important
I see so you don't think he was
expecting your line with A5 is what
you're saying yeah I think he didn't
expect and then later on after he
sacrifice the pound uh it was very
important to play Bishop A6 uh I I
actually fit this move in my nose but of
course I didn't remember
and well whatever I was
I was able to find it and so after
Bishop A6 I think that black is fine and
later on he played some something he
inaccurate moves I think E4 was already
wrong and I was much better already I
feel like he should have played
something else yeah and I was much much
better already A4 95 I could even take
one C5 oh okay let it be uh Let It Be A3
I see it was also
fine and then later uh
95.7 yes and
uh
I I think that later on just make it
go so yeah until you stop me yeah yeah
yes and and this will wait this was a
very important moment Queen 65 was
mistake I I spent a lot of time on
Bishop xc66 it was it was right
and so please move we should take 66.
uh and queen takes D6 was the problem
with index D6 root D6 E5 yeah Bishop J2
and here it was very important to play
Bishop B7 as otherwise he takes only
three so Bishop B7
uh Rook C7
yeah
[Music]
Bishop D5 now
so it seems like I'm losing the tempo
but in fact after okay three
um broke b it now I'm trading mate in
one and for example F3 and Knight E8
again very important and it should it
should be winning for
public slowly it was very important to
find that I didn't I didn't manage to do
it and then after 96
this should be very very drugged because
water played in the game uh well I felt
like okay there might be some chances
but of course it's
very small and Bishop 66 then I tried my
best from before it was
oh
later on I started to play very well but
of course he should he should not have a
lot this position uh I'm not sure about
Rook C4 actually I think that he lost
some time uh here
sometimes he should have played
something more actively even to give up
the pound at some point but to calculate
the pieces and to try to exchange the
night possibition and somehow killed at
the time and that then G5 Rook FC was
big big
losing of temples
I think after looking flicking G7 white
super white is very close to be lost
already
it's hard to believe but somehow
his pieces are very badly placed and I
think I didn't
spoil anything later so
rugby two and it's just impossible for
him to play and my next move is H4
yeah and his his King is just in a
mating net here it seems right yes yes
okay so a H4 and now I'm just simply
reading so just take one G3 and Rook C1
what I played and Knight cc is coming
you can get three Rook C2
wow
and it's important it was important that
Bishop D1 loses to uh
and then
then okay so he played some group before
and after an SSC I'm just winning and
change it's simply when
wow well that was some high level
analysis
um and a a good breakdown I guess of the
the critical game that has you moving on
how are you feeling right now about your
your chances overall obviously there's a
lot of Chess to be played but are you
feeling are you feeling in good form
right now
well I I I'm happy that I want to to
manages uh I don't want to think about
my chances because I just want to go
step by step I want to play
to to show my best well I think at some
point
I I played well and at some point I
wasn't precise what what the opponent
helped me a little bit and uh it's it's
also very important that when your
opponents helps you because without luck
it's impossible to win and okay I'll try
I'll try my best and now I'm looking
forward for the two other days in a row
what would what do you do with two rest
days in a row
I would clearly go to some mountains
um tomorrow with my wife and after
tomorrow we'll see I don't know if on
um obviously live analysis here any
other questions before we let Sergey go
maybe just say my question like whom you
like to be your ex opponent
did you follow their games
well my my next opponent will be the
winner of Guilford artemia so we'll see
hard to say that they're both very very
strong and
let them play a mentioned then and then
I will say you just want them you want
them to play as many games as possible
Right you want them to go to Armageddon
yeah would be nice but but in fact in
fact they will they will be um
after tomorrow so it doesn't matter so
much
well ifan and I have been trying to get
to some of the games we haven't looked
at yet so you mentioning that uh
obviously you're taking on the winner of
gelfind artemiev I think that's going to
be the match that we're going to head to
next while while you go enjoy your break
and while you're while you're there on
your rest day if you need something to
wear you can go to chess.com's merch
store in fact I'll send you a free
sweater what do you what do you want
anything you want um well thank you okay
we'll get you whatever you need
uh that was just my cue to head over to
the birth store because uh that's how
we're gonna head to a break and let
Sergey go Sergey thank you for being
with us and um best of luck in round
four
yeah good luck
and uh as we said everybody
um
Sergey is uh is gonna be enjoying his
rest days and and ifan and I are going
to take a look at at gelfin and
artemiev's game uh because that's one
that that uh that matters given the
interview we just had here so what's
going on we've uh We've likely got tie
breaks right now I mean well okay
artemium is a little better is black but
they drew their first game and this
looks like a very close position yeah it
looks like Josh almost uh close the
position right yeah
has uh finished his game I see radislav
in the background there and having drawn
Matt lakov that means that they will
also be headed to tie breaks so um
good luck to both of those guys playing
in tie breaks of round three matlakov
and voitashek
but all right let's go let's go back to
this artemium game because we haven't
looked at it yet
what do you think by the way in the
camera we saw that Fabiano sacrifice is
the real con F1 remember we just talked
with the possession went black six and
Fabiano
G5 and after Bishop F1 thinking maybe
he'll play Rockefeller than trying to
uh captured upon D5
okay one second we're gonna try to get
caught up here so after Bishop A6 he did
not play
he did not play Rook to F2
he played the move move G5 one second
okay
there we go we've got a full camera of
Fabiano there catching up to the
to the live game
all right so yeah let's go back to that
so Bishop A6 was played
and he played the move G5 wow
Bishop takes F1
can he take F6 here no he just takes
back yeah
I guess he'll he'll he'll try to take
the pawn D5 so the next one would be
important for black as I saw maybe
there's a possibility to attack the pawn
E3
but black could know why Google Rocky
why if black try some more like Queen E7
or 28 so that doesn't really change the
game
[Music]
wow this is
this is going to become a wild finish
here I mean we were talking about the
position being close to equal and and
suggesting
well on Bishop A6 looking at Rook F2 and
Bishop C4 Rook B2 but
Fabiano is uh
not interested in that more interested
in an all-in attack
I like it
yeah don't know if it's going to work or
not but I like it so what do you so how
does how does this game finish here what
are your
what are your nerves doing to you right
if you're if you're junior
I'm sorry
um
well I feel like um if black plays on
normal moves like 90 D7 now in 95 90 you
four states will become very tricky uh
but I didn't see anything better than
that means any Frozen noise to clarify
the position so probably yeah he went
for 98 by the way right but now the D5
Pawn will fall that's where yeah five
maybe Rook B5
and if you go
E4 then maybe he could try to sacrifice
The Rock back and play the move Knight
to C7
okay that's interesting and the point is
the bishop is kind of pinned to the D4
Pawn
right
well after Maybe
it makes a double throttle D4 and G5
right
instead of Rook D5 right
uh yeah before Rook takes a night maybe
okay
Knight to E6
yeah that actually looks really strong
[Music]
you'd love to have something with Knight
F6 check but it just doesn't work I mean
there's there's no there's no follow-up
to something like this I mean in
addition to the fact that D4 opponent is
hanging The Rook guards everything
you're not even checkmating so I I mean
I'm skeptical that Fabiano's Gonna Get
Enough compensation which
again in in regards to their
their particular matchup they drew their
first game so
it's critical yeah critical yeah this is
a loss here for Fabiano and he's uh he's
headed home from Sochi
well we don't know
but this game will become clear before
move 14 before the first time control
ends looks like
so we'll keep an eye on this maybe
we'll check some other games first and
get back to this one because they still
both have some time on the clock
yeah and you make a good point that the
the move 40 is still 12 moves away
uh Juma bayev has only 13 minutes so I
guess it was a practical decision from
Fabiano to try to justify this exchange
sack but uh but this this could be a
wild finish that maybe maybe sends uh
one of the top players in the world home
if you can't convert so all right one
other game to look at here before we
take before we take a break
um prognananda is still trying to
convert against
uh Michael krasenkoff and what a wild
position this is I know we've looked at
it already but
crazy look at that pawn on H7 for white
bought on C2 for black
this is crazy and he's only got four
minutes meaning meaning Prague
enough
and same salary because they just went
from Queen I took him before so maybe
Prague would be happy for a Perpetual
chat he don't need anything more than
that
foreign
yeah and again reminder when the match
situation is all Prague needs is a draw
here is black so even though he could
win it the threat there's also this
threat of Knight to C3 which okay you
come to E2 we that's uh that's Checkmate
if if nothing changed about the position
so you're saying this is likely likely
enough because white probably has
nothing better than this Perpetual here
yeah right
well looking at the Flying venue seems
like you know overall has finished as
well today the games yeah maybe it's the
second round there's so many games were
already done
yeah
second round seems to happen that way
too I guess those who those who can take
a draw because they're okay with tie
breaks some of them maybe do so
um others who had to win maybe got
themselves in tough positions and uh and
therefore the game was quick
um La one of the last games we haven't
looked at will just quickly Flash 2 is
Alexei shirov versus Nikita vichugoff
um
and uh
this is a wild one also one where uh one
of the players has to win that being
shiroff it's winner go home for the
Spaniard
but since like Sheriff again got some
good chances well not that many but
roxy796 well
if white could you know make use of
these
active pieces
and also the black screen on E6 it might
get some good chances but so far didn't
see any clear directions
could convert the initiatives
yeah
um and especially when you're in a
Muslim situation you can't you can't
settle on on small ways to convert you
got to look for something kind of
concrete
um
what is that plan for for sure off right
now
C7 is not hanging right because if Rook
takes C7
what does black have is black nine to D6
okay Rook takes C7 Knight to D6 yeah
because otherwise Bishop C4
uh yeah the thread is Bishop to C4
hitting F7 if you if you take here
something like this
would be or actually you could even take
G6 first probably
Maybe
um
okay so Knight D6 and this is
this is gonna have a lot of Chess left
here I mean I I think shirov does have
chances to win a game like this right
and he has to
yeah to listen there will be some play
especially when both sides are down the
clocks so
good choices will say yeah we're on move
so 13 moves to go until time control
and uh and then the camera we've got uh
we have my major of maybe we'll have a
quick look on that and game sure let's
do that look at mamajaro's game versus
Marty rosian again uh mama jarov
the highest rated player to have lost
his
um his first game in round three
and we see Mario brosn seems confident
there
looking confident but I'm not sure if
this expression looks confidence maybe
yeah I was gonna say but maybe not Maybe
not maybe he's working off in a little
bit of uh oh well we were we were
talking about this game it's like it
didn't seem like anything special for
for Mama jar right but this A3 Pawn
proving to be a Target like we said and
White's going to be pushing for two
results for the rest of game here
yeah but um white also got upon Israel
H5 like two weakness so
record F5 A3
oh
okay my major play the drop d one
would you ever played Rook C1
okay yeah and the point is he can give
up the H5 Pawn check because Bishop
takes would be met by C5 discovered
check and and probably just just winning
on the spot actually so so taking the
pawn is off the table
and
and I guess Rook D1 also just scared of
these three yeah and King A3 yeah
yeah because this A3 Pawn isn't going
anywhere so
sometimes you have to win on command and
it looks like Mama jar of might be able
to do that here
well another player who has to win on
command is Jeffrey Zhang who might might
actually be preparing to do so if on so
I'm going to look at that game when we
come back from a break but uh We've
we've reached our our end our end with
you it's it's pretty late
it's pretty late there for you so we're
gonna we're gonna let you check out but
this has been this has been a lot of fun
right good times
yeah definitely I have enjoyed to follow
the games and also then your uh great
comments so yeah it's great experience
well likewise it's always a pleasure and
uh you're bringing the the insights and
uh the the analysis that we can't get
anywhere else so thank you refund we
know that you're going to be with us uh
pretty much for the rest of month
whether it's myself or Daniel daradizki
who will be back and others so thank you
so much and uh we're gonna be right back
everyone don't go anywhere morpheide
World Cup with Grandmaster Ben Feingold
joining me on the other half
okay thank you man bye
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
and I know many have been wondering what
am I going to do to celebrate this
year's International Chess Day Ben I
know what you're going to be doing
you're going to be playing in the
24-hour Arena right
there's nothing in the world I'd ever
like to do more that's right Danny and
in fact you'll probably be streaming the
entire thing for all 24 hours right
you know if my wife would let me I
probably would do something like that
I'm not allowed to stream 24 hours for I
guess health reasons I don't know I know
Health right uh nothing crazy yeah but
uh Jokes Aside if you're looking for
something to do we're going to be doing
all kinds of fun stuff on International
chess day but one of those things is the
special 24-hour Arena that is July 20th
uh it's coming up and uh and anyway
International chess day it's a thing we
celebrate now almost as much as we
celebrate every time Ben wears a pink
shirt Ben that's correct it's not
exactly pink but it's close enough it's
salmon yeah yeah
I mean everybody keeps calling everybody
keeps calling me a fish so I wore a
salmon shirt it goes well with my blue
you and I I don't know this this thing
here this is this looks good together
right yeah it does yeah it does right
not even kidding yeah yeah it looks like
we color coordinated so all right well
we got some games to jump into Grand
Master Ben Feingold with us for those of
you who don't know him um well I just
don't think I don't think any of you
exist but you should go check out his
his twitch Channel but he and I'm gonna
be holding holding down the back half of
uh this game two of the of round three
of the feeder World Cup uh thank you
again obviously to Hobie Fawn who's been
with me for the first three hours and uh
Ben right before you joined ifan and I
were on the edge of our seed with this I
don't know are we going to be looking
back at it as a dubious Sacrifice by
carwana I have a feeling we might be
you know I think Fabi didn't like the
normal one you guys were looking at he
probably figured he wasn't better there
and you know since his opponent has a
little bit less time than him and it's
really tricky and also I think
in general
um and I'm a big fan of uh of of the the
guy who has black uh he plays wild and
crazy but I think he's more comfortable
attacking than defending okay it could
be psychological but yeah if two engines
are playing it's it's slightly dubious
yeah right
um of course the uh the sacrifice we're
talking about for those who who what Ben
just referred to is probably right he
just maybe he wasn't a fan of this
position Bishop A6 was played by Juma
bayev on move 26 Fabi neglected the idea
or or declined the idea of defending the
the past bee Pawn in this fashion and
instead played G5 sacrificing The
Exchange
which is What's led us to this
particular position we now have on the
board and uh you know that's an
interesting point right from a practical
point of view Juma bayev now has nine
moves to make in six minutes in a
position he's probably not that happy
with
yeah I think he he prefers to attack
and I think it's difficult to play black
but yeah of course that's that's more
psychological than uh than what you know
like engines say and you can't always go
by what what the engine says as far as
the Practical problems that are posed
and so somebody minus one in different
positions could mean like easy play for
black or it's minus one but you got to
play a lot of perfect moves so it's
difficult I'm with you I've been
justifying my blunders with that
mentality there you go no you know all
right no I'm kidding
um let's let's look at it quickly
there's some other games as well
although I think as far as big name
players in round three potentially
fighting for their lives we're gonna
have to keep a close eye on this for the
next 20 minutes for sure
um so let's just look quickly so F4 is
played let's say the queen just comes
back to d8 like that is that Jeffrey who
is that oh that is yeah oh wait yeah
let's head over there because yeah
somebody in the chat about 20 minutes
ago said he was winning
yeah but I never listened to chat you
know me oh looks like Chad was right
yeah holy shenanigans
that looks good for white yeah in a rare
turn of events twitch chat was correct
about something yeah that looks good for
white definitely that was a great game
yesterday that they played there was a
lot of twists and turns and you know
what else was even better about that
game was the commentary by a couple of
grand Masters I know named naroditsky
and Feingold you guys were fantastic
um it was fun looking at that game yeah
it was that was
I thought for a second there were some
wild lines where Knight to C7 was
actually better than Knight to G7 in the
end I'll just I'll even just I'll just
show that position real quick because it
was uh
it was actually you guys you guys had me
as a fan
on the edge of my seat wow there's so
many moves in this game Diana was the
game I know it was the end game on my
stream yesterday and there was some yeah
the first critical point was when white
sacrificed his Knight on B3 Jeffrey
blundered by taking it really yeah
Knight C3 check is a draw wow yeah and
that's King takes is losing it's just a
blunder wow yeah because then you forced
the white king you know way so you're
now you can go to D5 ah yeah you have to
play check while you're King yeah D4
Square yeah oh my God so that Queen in
two versus queen was a draw if Jeffrey
had played Queen e4check instead of
Queen H5 which is a very strange move
but one move number was that oh my God
it's
it was when it was Queen in two versus
queen and he played Queen H7 check for
the first time so it's even later okay
yeah keep going yeah
um
uh here yep yep no no go back yeah
go back oh yeah right here yeah Queen E4
check is a draw wow it's it's table
based so he might have lost but yeah
it's it's it's a table-based draw all
right well anyway sorry for that this is
just me uh
uh wanting wanting to know that
apparently we've got Fiddler and ship
Arena on the board now so that looks
like a draw lots of games finishing
quickly as you and I are going down the
rabbit hole of Queen and pawn endings um
so uh ship Arena and sfiddler draw their
game which means they are also headed to
tie breaks
um
I was just being a a chess fan here and
like I said watching naroditsky and
Feingold cover this yesterday yeah okay
so the point is it was a crazy
interesting game looks like Jeffrey had
his chances to draw that he missed but
ultimately when he needs to win to get
it done as I as I bring up the uh the
game here
Jeffrey gets a win
with the uh with the white pieces today
against Niels grandilius
yeah I unfortunately I played Jeffrey uh
about three weeks ago in the world open
and and I was like this guy's gonna do
good in the World Cup
he's he's just too good yeah fortunately
for me the last time I played Jeffrey he
was 14 years old
I have not I have not played Jeffrey
since he became the super Grand Master
that he is today so um sorry you had
sorry you had to experience that Ben I'm
with you buddy
um
but okay he gets credit because um
ifan and I were talking about this
position Ben as one bit while white is
up upon from the start of this
theoretical grunfeld it's a very hard
position for white to win so I just want
to quickly go through because he found
and I didn't really look at it past the
opening here and just see what happened
where did the blunder happen by
grundelius or where did Jeffrey come up
with a great idea
looks like maybe bishop takes C3 was
yeah because that pawn doesn't matter
very much oh wow you know he missed this
idea of Bishop E5 oh my gosh what about
easy yeah because it looks it looks like
Jeffrey blundered with Queen E3 because
Bishop D4 is going to G1 right so
granddelius should have been suspicious
like wait a minute Jeffrey's not
blundering that what am I missing well I
wonder if he already missed it here
because Queen F2 yeah it's really easy
to take for granted right he's thinking
he's gonna take on A7 yeah exactly it
almost feels like Queen of two is like a
draw offer and he's like okay C3 for A7
playing playing queen of two with the
idea of Queen E3 is already super sneaky
yeah no Bishop E5 that's that's almost
too hard for your uh you know puzzle
rush and yeah that's tough I think this
might already be winning I I if I
suspect Ben I think this was actually
the blunder he missed was Queen because
even though maybe he didn't see Bishop
E5 I don't think he has a choice here I
think he's already busted
yeah this isn't this isn't good for
black wow
what an awesome finish there and Jeffrey
Zhang forces tie breaks winning on
command against Nils Grand delius so um
it was like equal or slightly better for
white than black resign yeah three moves
we're moving into the back half here if
you're if you're just tuning in Where
Have You Been hoe fun uh left and now
Grand Master Ben Feingold and I will
have the call for the rest of the day
um still a lot of games going here
um but if you're if you're not happy
with whichever one we're covering you
can go to chess.com events and find the
one you want to look at let us know in
chat I apologize to chat for the for the
jokes about about rarely being right
about things but come on you know let's
self-reflect it's most the time true but
you were right Zhang was winning I
should have went to that game my bad
um
all right what about Magnus Carlson's
game with Ariana Ben it's likely a
foregone conclusion here but just
checking on it quickly because he is
Magnus Carlson just to make sure nothing
crazy is happening will chat opined
again about 20 minutes ago they said
Magnus was up four and now he's up 0.5
then they said he was winning again
obviously they're just using the engines
but this this doesn't look like a good
position for a white if he has to win
this looks terrible well I think even if
Magnus was up for everybody which I'm
not going to back up and look at this
one because there are some other more
interesting games to go to I think to
Ben's Point white can't win this
position likely right and remember
Ariana has to win this position or
Magnus moves on so um
yeah with that Bishop on C3 that's
that's not good for black for white yeah
that's um that's not good that's an
ideal yeah
the ship on F3 is no good either it's
black pieces are better than whites yeah
well so many games to look at um one
that we haven't jumped to for a while
and and again um keep an eye on the
fobby game if you would chat and let us
know if you think we should head back
there um because
that is a big one but I kind of wanted
to go back and look at the um
the prognananda game and make sure that
Prague is holding on against krasenkov
did he finish no he is not that's well I
like prog's position no oh my gosh but
wait
what's going on the engine says White's
winning
what is going on this has been this has
been a foregone conclusion ifan and I
have just been following this like okay
it's over white has to settle on the
draw
but of course we should know Crossing uh
krasenkop is not going to do that
because a drawing he can't do that right
it's just so he plays rookie one
and prognananda
has just blundered with Knight F4 but
what's the move why is it winning for
white I mean I don't I don't like Knight
F4 because
um I'm not sure what black does against
Rook E4 or Rook E3
and with the Knight on D5 you can't play
Rook E3 I think that I think the idea is
I think if rookie four you might have to
see one you can clean there no it's
track you can't it's true it's check oh
my gosh yeah I was looking at the
discovery okay yeah everything's checked
I need to Bishop E2 check it's just
check everywhere
oh my gosh if I play Rook E4 and you
play C5 I can take on C2
oh wow that's a fun point I don't I
don't know what black does here
what's going on Knight F4 oh my gosh
this is
I mean he doesn't have a lot of time on
his clock but yeah
he does have a lot of time but this is
shocking because it's been a game that
Prague has been in control the whole
time but we did we did have one sort of
foreshadowing thought the one issue was
his time pressure and we were pointing
that out that he was getting himself uh
low on the clock
oh krasnikov has played h8 Queen what is
the idea ah he's getting the queen away
so there's no tricks at all for black
and now rookie four is just winning yeah
yeah with the queen on H6 there's some
tricks but yeah yeah now there's the
queen NH it's no good
that's a super accurate you know kind of
engine like find H a queen
yeah that just distracts the queen and
all the knights are hanging in the C2
pawns hanging everything's hanging
but this is a shocking result here
everyone if fragnananda does not take
this game and heads to tie breaks that
could be a huge psychological blow
because he he was in complete control
over this game yeah I like Black's
position a lot yeah and has just
blundered it away
we see the young man on camera there I
think he knows he's in big trouble
yeah because sunkov looks super
confident
wow what a turnaround in one move that's
what happens in those positions yeah the
game changes on a dime which is
super complicated and one bad move ruins
it for either player and krasenkov has
taken The Confident stroll
right The Confident I think I'm suddenly
winning in a game I had no business
winning stroll yeah man man that feels
good
man prognan has not happy he is not
happy that is a frustrated young man and
that is a heartbreaker for the fans in
India
because I mean how do you handle that
Ben psychologically it's not even just
that you're you're probably going to
lose this game but you had you had it in
hand right and now you've got to
regather your emotions and fight for
your life for in tie breaks
yeah still if I have to pick somebody in
tie breaks I'm I'm picking Prague agreed
agreed pick the person who's 40 years
younger more than 40 years come on Ben
don't don't do yourself like that you're
better in Blitz than most 20 year olds
I'm gonna I'm gonna pick Prague over me
too and then some
if it makes you feel better I would also
take Prague over you that's right okay
um all right we need to go back to the
Juma bayev game versus Fabiano caruana
because we also have some action there
um
but wow crazy results coming in we see
if you're just tuning in we've seen
Jeffrey's young win to force tie breaks
yeah we've seen prognan to blow an
advantage and Juma bayev
is suddenly down a queen okay what
happened here we left it on F
yeah that that position changed a lot
yeah
okay we're gonna we're gonna refresh the
uh okay the board here I'm refreshed
are you just refresh your hair yeah and
my and yeah
okay now I'm refreshed perfect
um
okay well we've got the players fully on
on camera
and uh
and let's see here so F4 was played back
back to the analysis F4 was played and
Juma Baya plays Queen d8 F5
so this was it's kind of what you said
Ben you kind of said that objectively
regardless of Black's Advantage Juma
Baya might not be comfortable defending
and he makes a big mistake with Knight
F6
because after the trade on G6 he has to
sacrifice his Queen right yeah he's yeah
I wonder if he saw that yeah the reason
everybody is is Rook takes fails to
Queen A8 and we have yeah he I I'm now I
know he didn't see it yeah yeah because
he would have thought Rook takes a
missed Queen A8 that's reasonable
because Queenie it is stopped Queenie
it's hard to see yeah
especially when you know all your all
your focus is on the other side of the
board right yeah I think he just missed
it yeah you only have a minute look at
the clock right 49 seconds so
so he has to give up his Queen and
Fabiano's gamble might be paying off
this definitely looks easier for white
to play with the queen and the past deep
on but but it's not over yet right the
two I mean because here's the thing
right if if somehow the D is traded for
B and all we're doing is focusing on one
side of the board the Rooks are totally
fine here against the queen
yeah and also if black can keep his B
Pawn he can but I think it's too much to
ask I think there's excellent drawing
chances for black but I don't think
Bobby's in trouble like he may have been
I think Bobby's happy now
agreed and he's not he's not in the
must-win situation they drew the first
game so right no he's pressing to our
point and we're also still we still have
not reached time control so
um three more moves have to be played
for Juma bayev so he's not out of the
woods yet with only 49 seconds on the
clock
yeah maybe it's a draw with correct play
but I definitely want to have white
two past pluns is two past Pawns two
best pawns is two past spawns
that's
can we add that to the fine gold
um isms I I have stole that from
fedorowitz so I'm tweaking with
fedorowitz head okay well as you said
this is no longer the drama it was
because while Fabi might be playing for
two results the point is if it happens
to be that that peaceful result then
neither player is going home so let's go
look at the the game that I saw chat
mentioned just a moment ago head over to
cindarov's game again um for those who
didn't get the memo the young man from
Uzbekistan sent all the Reza farrugia
home in the last round and now
now looks to be winning against Jorge
Corey so this guy Sandara right circle
circle that name as yet another maybe
potential future world championship
Challenger
I had a very similar ending against Sam
shankland in like the 2000s
seven or eight U.S championship in Tulsa
yeah it was it was two against two on
the king's side I had a pass Pawn on the
Queen's side and his Rook at night were
blocking it and the way I won was I kept
moving my king to different sides of the
board until his defenses broke down
although here black has an a pawn but I
don't see how that matters so
uh see like it does anything so it
should be winning for why but this this
may take a while if black gets a
blockade right it might not be easy
yeah especially if you can find a way
for both the Knight and Rook to blockade
one square the way that normally works
is like a knight on E6 yeah and then the
Rook the point everybody is sort of free
it doesn't have to be on C7 to be
blockading C7 and because White's pawns
aren't healthy meaning they're not
together that also could pose a little
some limitations right but I mean for
for sure objectively white should be
winning right like yeah but it's not
easy yeah so it's gonna be a long game
yeah but I like your advice there you
know sort of balancing both sides of the
board like whether it's the king or like
the queen will often sit on squares
where it can kind of do two things at
once poke at the open King and help the
Sip one advance and then you you
eventually just pull a Georgian Grand
Master meaning you never actually found
a concrete win you just posed enough
problems and your opponent beats
themselves yeah right
um that's the Georgian Grandmaster
special I call it
um
well I'm from Georgia so perfect
what you well you are from Georgia now I
live in Georgia yeah that not the
Georgia I was talking about but well you
know I'm from a Georgia
although Brooks rookie five that was
interesting right because now he wants
to do the same idea I said Ben but maybe
with the C5 square and the reason I like
that is that actually prevents the
king's progress right because it holds
the fifth rank in some way so still
still objectively probably white is fine
but that's an interesting one
yeah this game is not a foregone
conclusion at all either results
possible yeah okay
um where to now um remember everybody
you can choose your own adventure we got
3 000 of you on YouTube 12 000 of you on
Twitch and
and many others across the the interwebs
maybe watching this on replay so if
you're watching this in the future hello
future we're from the past that's
correct
um especially me especially let's go to
grishek's game
because because grishek NP show are
under mutual time pressure I feel like
these you guys probably just agreed
before the game started to get under
time pressure together right and grishek
won the first game right yeah yeah yeah
yeah I saw a tweet that um grishek is
being all the Argentinian players
yeah might have been from you guys
I don't know no one even knows who runs
our Twitter account anymore to be honest
well that's good yeah let me ask you
don't tell like someone was like looking
for the password the other day and we're
like I think we gave it to the intern
and no one's been logged in for months
so
uh
all right
let's talk about grishek's game before
we head over to Young Christoph dude I
see some of the chat wanting to check
out sevian versus JKD
all he needs is a draw situation he's
got to be happy it looks pretty equal
yeah this looks fine
yeah I'm sure grishek's happy with this
position he's gotta pass deep one his
rook's on the open file his Knight's on
B4 uh looks fine
yeah
and for grishook he has a lot of time
more than a minute
he's got more than a minute to play six
moves I mean that's yeah that's an
eternity he's probably taking a nap yeah
yeah this looks like uh the show's only
chances if um Grisha blunders before the
time control hits because this just
looks equal yeah
yeah and with um
yeah grishek's one of the big favorites
this tournament because he's so good at
everything yep slow chest Blitz rapid
yeah it is one of those things where you
you look at the the maybe not inevitable
but the likely possibility of tie breaks
in so many matches that guys like Grisha
really bring
um a lot a lot of prowess um
so
okay I see a lot of chat requesting for
all kinds of games we know you want
videos game I see people requesting core
above's game young Christoph dudas so
again this is not a
this is uh not avoiding you know making
everyone happy but the reality is you
can check out all the games at chess.com
events and we will do our best to keep
up so let's go to John Kristoff's game
neither player has anything real on the
line and so I don't think we're going to
spend too much time here because most
likely this will be a draw and we'll
have tie breaks between these two
that's the most likely but it looks like
Judah is pressing a little bit a little
bit so how do you give us the give us
the bend Feingold Rook ending experience
right well sometimes King and pawn
endings you're drawn and sometimes
they're lost and black has to be careful
in the king and pawn endings that white
doesn't scooch up to h5h6 which looks
like another famous ending
um I guess that was Rubenstein yeah I
think that yeah and
it looks like that's going to be okay
for black because I think black very
quickly could just win the a pawn yeah
so I don't think I don't think white can
do that now what what he did do is he's
sacrificed his Apon because he wants to
play Rook H5 Rook H7 getting a past H
Pawn and attacking F7
yeah and
and that could be a rook ending that is
that is actually kind of hard to hold as
much as it first sounds like okay eye
for an eye a trade this is such a
healthier
such a healthier past Pawn for white and
likely this Rook will find find a way to
get behind and get access to maybe F7 in
the process yeah but even if you don't
take the F Pawn you can play like H6
rook h8 and Black's King can't get over
there right so that's that's not good
it's just better for white yeah yeah so
Sam is going to have to have good
defensive technique to hold this this is
just advantageous to why I was gonna say
is it that strong that maybe you have to
play E5 and then even though I was
laughing when you made the joke that
some King upon endings were drawn and
some are lost maybe you were serious I
think it's actually really instructive
because basically what you're saying is
if this side of the board is simplified
then all of a sudden this sort of
structure becomes much more of a problem
in a case yeah that's not as good as
what's the point on E6 yeah so so if if
this is a real problem and and we see
Savion have to play E5 here
maybe Judah has more chances than I
first gave you yeah and the Judgment
comes in because you can't calculate
with two minutes on your clock you just
calculate a little bit and then you
guess like Rook A4 E5
right and you get it you gotta decide
you know what's
they both have their issues so
it's not easy
it's never easy
for sure so yeah I don't know I don't
know what he should do I don't I don't
really like either line for black
probably perfect plants to draw but
foreign
to play perfectly in time trouble and
it's you have some decisions to make
well speaking of time trouble we're
gonna have a lot of games entering it so
we're going to take our last very very
quick break before we bring all of these
games to their conclusion so don't go
anywhere Grand Master Ben Feingold uh
with us now and we will be right back
with more it's the second set of games
for round three the 2021 feed a World
Cup more action in just a moment
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and for all those of course wishing they
had Grandmaster Donya narodiski back
uh we've got a reminder that the
blitzcoin Invitational is coming up on
October 27th an event that Dania is uh
gonna be gonna be starring in sponsored
by the Charlotte chess Center we're
super excited about it it's going to be
featuring 16 of the young Elite American
players under the age of 25 their prize
just as you can see is a Bitcoin they
are splitting the value of a Bitcoin so
let's hope that that thing continues to
go up and that Elon Musk keeps his keeps
his mouth shut wait did I just say that
but anyway for those who's wishing
donya's back but he's not guess who's
back
back with Ben back with Ben the other
Daniel Danny's back tell a friend
guess who's back guess who's back well
we're back to Magnus who's by the way
just just just holding on here this is
kind of a foregone conclusion he's going
to draw this game and so we're going to
be focused on some others he'll be
moving on
um
yeah this is a very bad position for
white in a must-win situation
right does this just never win you could
move back to uh you can't win
I will go back to Juma bayev's game
versus Fabiano caruana just real quick
to check on it
um
by the way I guess we should just show
let's just show the result prognananda
did go on to lose that game with
krasenkov what an absolute Heartbreaker
and uh well timed there by my producer
who just brings it up on cue I literally
saw the result hit our relay here at the
chess.com events page and again it all
started with the uh with just the the
terrible blunder
just yeah
I mean
everything was going well for Prague
this position here
well a lot of them were winning but
we'll just get to one that it seemed
seemed over krasikov plays rookie one
and queen takes H7 was actually probably
just the simplest Win Ben just take the
pawn
that was that was the easiest win but
Prague blunders with Knight F4 and just
like that you see the evil e-bell bar
the evil eval bar slide up the board
AJ Queen and rookie four and the game is
over and yeah your nights are forked
yeah
huge heartbreak yeah
so Prague will now have to play tie
breaks the next day
okay yeah I think he's still the
favorite but that's uh yeah that's
unpleasant yeah
yeah well I mean what would you you have
a lot of students right and uh you're
pretty good at what you do so advice you
give to Prague give us your 30 second
pep talk the clean version the clean
version the clean version man that'd be
like one second
um yeah you just tell them that the
match is one one it's time for a new
match it's advantageous to you you're
the better player you're higher rated
you're younger that your opponent's
exhausted you know and that's the way
chess is now you now you get to beat him
again
right and uh you know just you just have
to forget about it and new chess starts
right that's what happens these things
happen all the time in The Knockouts you
know there's somebody blunders and it's
time for time for playoffs yeah it's
always funny all good pieces of advice
come back to Ted lasso you just got to
be a goldfish have a short memory yeah
that's it it's Gotta Have a short memory
and everything will be fine uh speaking
of having a short memory mom and Yara
doesn't remember that he lost game one
Ben and he he might also be about to win
and send this thing to tie breaks
I mean yeah big big advantage to White
obviously
better King better Rook better
ingredients Papa mamajaro I mean
oh man now this this isn't good for
black black now black has counter play
if he can play rookie three and rookie
two
but I mean his King is in a little
trouble the C Pawn is going to be passed
it's hard for Black's pawns to get going
even if he wins some pawns but to see if
he takes the bee Pawn that c Pawn is
pretty quick
so big advantage to uh mama jarov and
this is his chance to tie the match
and uh and he knows it
he knows his position is pretty good
we had a great view there too of uh
capturing
capturing mamajara's face but through
those two kings whoever was doing the
camera work there fantastic
um
yeah he looks really focused
yeah I tried it yeah that was nice I
tried to get my my students to look that
focused but uh I guess trying is the
first step to failure trying is lying as
one of my abusive aunts used to say okay
that's good only one of your abusive
ants not the other one yeah troying is
lying if if you were told hey you gotta
try something you say I'm trying and
then then she would say trying is lying
and it never well when you have ants
like that you got to get an exterminator
that's the problem exactly we have ants
oh man all right back to the chest away
from My Dysfunctional Family okay so
mama jarv is uh
is uh playing like a goldfish has no
memory of his loss and and uh maybe
maybe sends this thing to tie Breakers
what else do we have no but this but
this is one of the advantages the older
player has we we have to have some
advantages and and that is we we've lost
before these things happen and the
younger players a lot of time haven't
experienced this heartbreak where
everything is going great you're about
to win and then everything goes wrong
that that's happened throughout your
career but if you're 14 years old it
hasn't happened a lot so you know he's
like yeah I lost all right time to win
that's you know I'm white I'm the high
rated player I should win with white
so he's not not as perturbed as maybe
prognanda is now for losing a winning or
better position but you know get over it
no totally fair and and it's obviously
not just kind of like you know General
statements into the air I think it's
super critical an event like this where
like it's it's a long event you know
getting keeping yourself in the right
frame of mind is is half the battle and
uh and these guys with experience you
know know how to not kick themselves
when they make mistakes and just move on
to the next game
um speaking of moving on let's let's
check back in with the the games at the
uh the top of the women's section we
haven't actually been over there in a
while
um unfortunately for Carissa yet it
doesn't look like she rebounded from the
opening blunder where hoey Khan and I
left her
um it was a wild a wild opening been but
ultimately Carissa
looks like she sacrificed a piece and it
wasn't good and so um
and now now I think she's about to go
down to uh zagmeesi here
yeah in fact looking at the engine
evaluation a barg I I'm surprised
Black's not doing even better
yeah I'm like how do you deal with queen
of two why is this not why is this only
yeah I mean queen F2 wins Queen H2 wins
but just what there must be an only move
here for white we're not seeing it it's
probably like a a move like Rook G2
where no human even looks at that move
because you just know you're going into
the Lost ending but yeah that's probably
the only move
well yeah you can't allow Queen F2 or
queen H2 so
but if but if the reason it's only so
winning is because of that right because
now even though this is in an easy win
for black I mean some of us might even
be like just Rook up and you're up two
pawns and a rook ending it's it's still
gonna take a little bit of technique
that's all yeah so it looks like it'll
go into tie breaks yep which isn't
necessarily in favor of anyone because
obviously Chris is going to be great at
uh at rapid and Blitz
always bet on the younger player
but yeah that's uh that's unfortunate
because she won a nice game with black
yesterday
yep is she the only American woman left
that's what I thought but I wasn't sure
um I actually don't know I didn't have
my my fact check ready for that so maybe
we'll ask the stats yeah I thought there
were four men and one woman but maybe I
miscounted both sections I wasn't
counting I was just thinking about who
was playing yep because the American men
didn't do well yesterday yeah it was not
a
was not a good a good day
um let's let's look at the top of the
section garage Kina is in a in a
commanding spot given that she won the
first game and this looks to be pretty
close to equal I'm not sure how uh
badelka holds on to to winning chances
when she's down upon in the end game
uh yeah this isn't a good must win plus
this is a forking problem on C5
she fixes the forking problem but still
yeah in fact uh
I mean you could even play Knight C5 and
Knight E4 if you want
I don't see why that's necessary but you
could
when you're already applawn up and you
know pawns are all on the same side
but yeah I mean if I if I was in a must
win for black I'd be pretty happy here
because there's winning chances must win
for white not not as happy right
all right so garage Gina looks to be
looks to be in control
um taking a look at stefanona
stefanova's game versus pogonina
oh something
has not gone well here for Natalya
no what whites up in exchange whites
Queens on d8
the Bishops are bearing down on Black's
King the pawns are coming
yeah this is uh this is tough for black
do you know what happened in their first
game
uh in the first game uh it was a draw so
neither player was in mussman territory
but it looks like stefanova might
deliver regardless yeah G5 and G6 is is
a real problem
yeah this I mean this is this is
terrible
yeah this looks like a sicilian gone
wrong for black it actually wasn't it
was funny because I was saying that it
had the potential to be like a dragon
Sicilian but the opening was a weird a
weird I mean the Eco says the Falk beer
variation of of some of the any game and
who gives a bleep right the point is
kind of a weird a weird line
um but yeah I think they just they just
transposed into the um Center game yeah
right and and Yvonne and I were saying
after H3 maybe B5 was the move we
actually we actually looked this was the
last time we looked at this position and
we had analyzed B5 takes and Bishop D7
as like a practical try for black but
um Natalya took the more uh solid
approach but now that means that that
means that white kind of gets ahead in
the race a little bit with G4 okay wait
she did go for the B5 idea later
eventually yeah
but stefanova just played in the center
with the extra Pawn I like that yeah
this is just bad for for yeah this just
looks
[Music]
straightforward for white as Yasser
would say white has the pawns and the
compensation yeah
yeah this is just terrible yeah the
whole game was just no fun for black
yeah owie that's a nice trick Knight F6
taking Queen F6 made so yeah I'll just
show it again
can't take Boomtown
so
okay well it does look like um
yeah it does look like
like stefanova's gonna convert so let's
check in quickly with any other game
still going of relevance here Collision
is Kaya
uh
Collision skya is actually doing doing
well and because she also won the first
game I think we can pretty much punch
Alina's ticket into the next round
right this is just yeah white has zero
chance to do anything right
ones look at real quick we will
Elizabeth
uh
Elizabeth Potts is
um someone who's created some content
for our German chefs Community here on
chess.com they drew the first game but
she looks to be in uh in a really great
spot here it's obviously good Bishops
but she's got good winning chances yeah
with the Rooks on the board in the past
apron yeah King side solid it should
just be a win
yeah
yeah she should win this okay
all right well I'm being told we have
another interview potentially coming
um and we know that um
as much as they they love your pink
shirt Ben I think they love hearing from
the players on site even more
possibly
we have to give the people what they
want take a quick break don't go
anywhere when we return more uh game two
round three action from the feeder World
Cup as well as an interview we'll be
right back
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and we are back here with a very special
guest Alexander grishek who moves on to
round four in Sochi uh Alexander what
are you going to do with two rest days
what do you mean about two there is one
more but you don't you don't have to
play tomorrow because you have a tie
break so you get two rest days in a row
I didn't know there is a rest day after
this round yeah July 21st
so you're gonna you're gonna just hang
out go for a walk you get a party what
are you gonna do as I told you I just
got this information so I always don't
have any plans okay well
um uh Alexander Jokes Aside Ben and I
Ben and I were just talking about you uh
before we knew you were gonna join us as
a player who we see as as very difficult
in this format because you are so good
at at the potential type ring formats
you're one of the better rapid and Blitz
players in the world and so do you
consider yourself someone who is is it
difficult a difficult opponent for
people in the in the feed a World Cup
format
okay I think it's more difficult than
ever is success
but nothing special something special
okay
Ben uh you have to disagree with that I
think you're one of the big favorites is
that and you have so much experience at
every time control and it seems like
when we watch you play you don't feel
the pressure like some of the other
players are are you surprised more at
this event the young kids who are doing
really well like cinderell we're at the
older guys like you're given christenkov
who are doing well what surprises you
more yeah I think today is the
crescenkov's game was amazing I haven't
studied it yet but just from the brief
loop it's
absolutely great
just I mean it was was beautiful very
intense everything and also very
important from sport point of view
so yeah but also of course in that of
beating ferrugia was amazing especially
the style he was not like you know like
like this like this and then one punch
he was just playing on completely even
jobs and even I would say some were
dominating the format
yeah
well as the event goes on do you feel
like uh it favors the the young or
favors the experience and I'm not it's
not a trap question but as it goes on do
you feel like you get you get better as
it goes because you've been here before
or do you feel like the younger players
get more confidence
I don't know I I generally think when
someone qualifies to the some round
whether it's the fourth round or
semi-finals finals it means he deserved
it there are no undeserved winners so
I'm not thinking about such things what
favors movements so on one thing I
wanted to say about those young guys is
that because of this pandemic and lack
of tournaments for more than one year
they are very underrated right because
they just could not play and get this
Rich so like this Cinderella is maybe I
don't know 25.50 but his real level is
let's say 27 so uh it's just a very
unlucky baby for for those who meet them
right because you are supposed to meet
some average 25 50 person and you meet a
very very strong plan yeah yeah it's
such a such a unique environment I mean
no we've never had an event like this
right after a year and a half off after
a global pandemic so it's an interesting
story but yeah I mean and it's I mean I
mean in fact I think it's not such a big
sensation as it looks because in fact
it's like 27 and 50 player lost to 27
players not 27 50 to 25.50 right right
no it makes sense
well speaking of who you're going to
meet are you already aware of who you
might play in the next round
yes it's most likely korov but I don't
know what happens in his game against uh
Georgio
he's he's actually he's actually still
playing right now but it it looks like
it'll it'll be uh well actually no uh
you're you're uh has some chances to
maybe win and send a tie break so yeah I
mean usually such end games they are
there are no chances it's either one or
with the road you know
because there is just very little
resources for both sides so right it I
think it's most likely a draw but I
cannot I would not bet my life
okay
well um what else should we talk about I
feel like I just want to hang out with
you what else do you want to talk about
hey you know it's a fun fact that my
first two opponents were roommates that
they said okay fun fact yeah they are
not just boss from Argentina
but they were actually sharing the same
room so you're you're literally An Enemy
of the State down there you're not
welcome in Argentina I don't know they
were both very friendly after our
matches boss looks look like very nice
guys so I hope I'm not and also I want
to congratulate the Argentinian people
with victory in Copa the America beating
the Brazil in the final yeah it was a
long they were waiting for this for a
long long time shout out to Messi shout
out to me yeah I agree
um Ben any other comments before we uh
before we let uh Mr Grisha get going
um well congratulations on your win good
luck in the next round and uh I think
you're I think you're gonna do well so
thanks thanks for the interview and
thanks for the great game so far there's
so many good games in this tournament
and there's there's just no quick draws
everybody's really fight lighting and of
course you're always fighting so it
makes the tournament better for
everybody thank you thank you now I need
to make a PCR test so oh wow wish me
luck I need I need good luck with that
too good luck good luck with the chat
okay okay take care take care all right
bye bye Sasha all right everybody we're
going to take a very quick break don't
go anywhere we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
and we are back here round three game
two day two of the 2021 feeder World Cup
what a great interview with uh Alexander
Grisha Sasha grishek as he's known and
uh I so much to unpack about what he
said Ben and we'll get into it but I I
want to jump right in to the game with
Fabiano and uh jumabaya because what has
happened here this has become a three
result position Ben I mean I think we're
back to a situation where
where any anybody could win right I
think it's going to be a draw but fabi's
not not the one who's uh obviously
pressing here yeah so when Ben and I
left it the tactic that we we we assumed
uh Juma bye must have missed was right
here everyone Knight F6 was played and
it was a blunder as you can see because
after the trade and Bishop takes F7 you
can't take with the Rook due to Queen A8
check very nice tactic yeah so Bobby
wins the queen but what but something
else happened while we were gone Here
Comes Knight F5 E4
Knight H4
king of H3
yeah this is that's not a good King this
is this is spicy
and then Queen C4
wow
wow I mean that's a yeah
I don't think that was right
but I don't know why it was a blunder I
hate when the e-bal bar is evil and it
tells us there's a blender and I don't
know why I mean
but let's see what happened Knight H oh
not no not Knight F4 he plays H5 I guess
the point is the king is sort of Trapped
actually look yeah Knight F4 and Rook G4
is Checkmate right that's right
that's that's amazing yeah the King on
H3 is really bad
it's really bad what it what a what a
weird blunder to make right I mean you
play Queen C4 and your opponent goes H5
and you go oh
oh you know what oh explicit because you
can't stop you can't stop Checkmate you
have to give up your night right
yeah that's not what he was yeah
that's amazing he kept with the King G2
to H3 yeah yeah this position is
difficult black black got a nice attack
with Rook G5 Knight G6
okay well now
um Juma bayev is thinking
they have made it past time control so
he will have enough time on the clock
this is this is the kind of game that I
would expect black black to win to be
honest and I know that yeah I think it's
I think it's a True Result game now the
other way I think it's black winds are a
draw yeah because what do you do if I
just if I just enter like I'm just gonna
play the most obvious move on the board
well I'll have to defend with my queen
and then if you take it it's a draw but
uh okay yeah there's Knight F4 check
kind of thing sometimes I don't know
you're just losing
yeah I mean Black's King is very safe
because you can always block with the
Rooks and the Knights and the center
pawns aren't helping White's King but I
think this was really bad from Fabi King
G2 to H3 he just underestimated how bad
his king would be
yeah so you're saying right back here
when he when he kind of invited this
whole night age four check King H3
yeah that King's just not good on H3
yeah and here he has to play Super
precise but I mean you just can't do
that with a clock situation you got to
move eventually yeah so I mean engines
would draw here with white but the
humans are just going to be like how do
I stop all of this right
so Queen c4h5 and then
like it's funny he you know he he got
the position that he wanted where he was
attacking that's the way he likes to
play and you will buy oven yeah and
finally he started attacking yeah
yeah the table's turned and Juma Baya
was back in his comfort zone yeah this
guy's underrated too I've been a fan of
of juabaya for a while because he the
the style that he plays is so aggressive
yeah
and uh yeah jumbo as he's known on
chess.com
you said he's he's underrated as well I
mean grishek left us with that kind of
nugget during the interview highlighting
sundara's victory over farouja right
obviously you have these guys that are
he said you're supposed to play like
some easy 25 50 because you're 27.50 but
it's more like a 2750 playing a 2700
yeah um and you know what what are your
thoughts on that how much the pandemic
has sort of changed the game we don't
know how to evaluate these these these
players who played a whole bunch online
over the last year that's right it's
funny because there's two kinds of
players and in our chess Center here we
have a lot more unrated players than
usual and one of that is because you
know the Queen's Gamba and people
started playing chess again and one is
people who played on chess.com casually
this is that was their only hope so they
were playing so much more chess online
and they got more interested in chess
that people who are new who played for
like a year and a half and never played
in a tournament
those are the strongest unrated players
I've ever seen like unrated players are
like oh chess let me go play the
tournament and you know how they play
right but these people are experienced
they've played you know 17 18 1900
players for a year and a half right and
so these unrated players are beating 14
15 16 1700 players conversely the people
who just played in tournaments their
whole life who are older like maybe me
they didn't play for a year and a half
they didn't play then when they come
back they're like wait what's happening
so if you didn't play online for a year
and a half you're in a big hole no it's
it makes it makes a lot of sense and I
mean to elaborate that you you're saying
you're you're literally experiencing
some of the strongest unrated players
you've ever seen in chess clubs right
now for sure when rated players are just
see before when unrated players were
beating everybody years ago we were like
hmm does this guy have a secret rating
in some other country does he have a fee
day rating right now we don't suspect
that we just know that they've played
online for a year and a half right and
they're good
yeah so yeah no it's it's wild um and I
remember those experiences before the
internet I'm I'm uh I'm pretty much as
old as you right
um but you know no sit around
um you know but I remember although the
experience where you have someone and
then everyone is talking like where is
this guy from right the inner online
didn't exist and and then but now it's
just you know I guess people are like
yeah well they've been playing on you
know chess.com for two years and they're
really good so um yeah
wow okay well um
where to go now uh jumabaya might
convert this one and Fabiano might be
headed home yeah fabi's definitely
trying to draw this yeah he'll be happy
with the draw
okay well a lot of other games to still
look at um Magnus Carlson and Ariana are
still playing
um
so shout out to the younger Norwegian
for not giving
up or maybe Magnus is just like playing
with his food who knows right
um maybe Magnus hasn't offered a draw so
so Ariane has no choice but to continue
to be tortured
yeah I mean it's I I don't even have a
winning plan for whatever and he has to
win so that's that's no fun yeah that's
that I think that just knows he can't
lose he just wants to try to win because
why not
yeah
for those for those missing the context
of that joke the reason this is torture
for Aryan is because he has to win so he
is just lost I mean this is
uh this is not not a fun situation to be
in so all right we'll come back to that
scrolling down continuing to look at
matches that have not finished yet one
match that we just haven't looked at at
all probably the only one so I feel like
we owe it is punk cradov's game versus
vaquita
um
in this particular matchup Punk carotov
has to get the W but he but maybe
just maybe you're saying there's a
chance maybe it's up for exchange for a
Pawn Yeah and uh yeah this is good
winning chances for white very good
winning chances
okay so we could have another must win
situation
um I was talking to Johnny yesterday we
were I was surprised because I didn't
think there were any father-son GMS but
this is a father-son GM here
he's a GM and so is his dad yeah and um
you know Magnus is one of the few
players when he needs a draw if he's
better he plays for the win he's done
this more than once yep and um even
against Anand in the world championship
against Iranian in this in the um
a draw wins the tournament and he would
just win yeah he doesn't want to draw so
that's good for the spectators
um Yep this looks very likely like like
White's gonna win and force the playoff
and this tournament in particular
there's very few draws and there's no
quick draws which is really refreshing
from what I've been seeing online lately
this is a big fighting tournament people
haven't had a chance to play a lot of
Chess it's two-game knockout there's a
30 move draw rule I think and these are
just the most fighting games this
tournament even even if there's not a 30
move Joel you're right it's just better
it's just more exciting I mean it's it's
why
for my for my money as a chess fan and
commentator just you know I'll be biased
to my own point of view I think the
feeder World Cup is maybe my favorite
event and even more than the World Chess
Championship Match itself not because
it's like the stakes are the highest and
there's it's intense but this event just
has so much drama and so much fun and
how often do you see the world's Elite
get paired against 2550s who UPS who Who
deliver the upset right it just doesn't
happen and not to you know not to lay
you know beat the dead horse about how
much none of us want to see more more uh
more easy draws among the world's Elite
but I agree with you this this event is
just so much fun yeah and in fact I've
complained on my stream before that back
you know back in the day you know 50s
60s 70s 80s it was common for the best
players in the world to play in
tournaments with people who weren't in
the top hundred and then those games are
interesting because the higher rated
player wants to win right you didn't see
quick draws then either unless they're
playing each other but now
normally if you see somebody who's in
the top 10 and somebody else that means
everybody is right and there's there's
quick draws of the games don't have a
lot of blunders and the reason this is
exciting not just because of the the
players are playing to win is because
there's a lot of games so you always
have a game to go to that's super
exciting right
yeah and that's true because you know
the other way to look at sometimes draws
I agree with you that the the system is
different now in the 50s 60s 70s 80s the
top players in the world played in more
open events or or more events against
lower rated players but so even if we
remove that part of it sometimes a draw
is a reflection of very high level chess
right that is the the the other way to
wrap a ribbon around the elephant which
is saying that it's very well prepared
very high level chess but the thing is
like it's just that it can also be
reflective of protecting your position
right and and we've seen controversies
on social media where players say well I
don't want to lose rating points because
then I don't get invited so it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy that I'm going
to draw some of these games right and
I'm not naming them by name but it you
know so the system I'm kind of saying
the the phrase of what is it don't hate
the player hate the game and I do think
the game is something that has changed
for the top level players and so they're
not taking as many risks so I'm gonna
take the don't hate the player hate the
game approach because sometimes the
players are well prepared playing the
best chess in the world world and
they're doing their job but the system
doesn't challenge them to play risky
chess like the fide World Cup does right
so right so I think that that's a good a
good nod for a tournament like this
which is a lot of fun so okay um enough
of that rant let's go let's go check on
bidet gujarati's game Punk runoff might
win on command there and it didn't win
the first game well I did it I was about
to say Punk runoff might win on command
there and the Beast adibon baskaran
might win on command here as well and
send it to tie breaks against his
countrymen I like white a lot yeah one
on G6 kills the bishop two to one on the
queen side the Deep one's not dangerous
very difficult for black
I wow what a Bennett was doing well
earlier when he when he fought was was
was here
but as long as
as long as Audubon keeps the Queens on
the board I'm thinking like a queen C4
check right don't trade Queens with
Oscar Bishops or or maybe this but if
the Queens stay on the board feels it's
definitely a two result position for
white yeah the black yeah the black king
is is not good and and even
um there are positions where trading
Queens wins too because the white pawns
are so far apart
um yeah if you just put the bishop on D3
the d-pawn's not dangerous and so black
has to dance at two weddings it's not
clear that you can stop white from
winning there either
yep all right let's go back to the game
just in a lot of trouble yeah I mean
there's a lot of games with a lot of
trouble and we're gonna go back to the
game with Fabiano because
um
I think I speak for a lot of fans who
wouldn't be excited if the American was
sent home but he kind of got himself in
this scenario and he uh
he's in trouble here Ben this is
yeah he's fighting for his life here
yeah King G3 King G2 King H3 was was
very bad
he'll be so happy if he holds the draw
because it's you know
his opponent's super confident now
but White's King is just in a world of
hurts if Knight F4 check is played are
we not just looking at a forced
I don't understand why there's not a
mating net ensuing let's look at Knight
F4 check okay the
oh those possible King H4 is better he's
gonna say maybe he can just walk up wow
I mean man I I wouldn't be happy it's
it's not happy but it's like where's the
mate right that's probably his plan is
to just walk into the face yeah I think
it I think it's King H4
because yeah with the night out on G6
now White's got some tracks that Queen
h8 check which if he gets that and he'll
be okay
okay so that means Knight F4 is not as
good as I I was looking at Knight F4 and
just and for some reason I thought you
had linking H2 which is just it's going
to be mate here there's no way there
isn't some sort of I don't know some
sort of mating net yeah this this isn't
good for white no so but the fact that
fobby can play King H4 means Knight F4
is not as big of a threat as I thought
right and the thing is white white at
the moment doesn't have counter play
like
white White's Queen basically has to
stay on the G3 pawn and as a consequence
white can't play E5 because that blocks
his Queen
so white black means to like build but
I'm not sure because Black's pieces all
look so good I'm not sure how to make
them better they're just they're all in
the right positions yeah and if if
you're not moving the Knight with Tempe
like I said then then you're allowing
Queen h8 in every position too yeah so
maybe he could take his Rook on G5 and
swing it over to A1 A2 or A3 because
that Rook isn't really needed to stop
checks the 99 G6 is doing a good job
uh-huh and he could also use his other
Rook to like for example if he plays
rookie three you can't play E5 yeah and
you can't you can't let him take your
e-pawn and you can't defend your e-pawn
with your queen because the G3 Pawn's
hanging actually now that you say that
rookie three looks like a fantastic move
yeah
normally I need like five engines to
find a good move but normally
sometimes five you know yeah no but Rick
I mean the fact that white doesn't have
counter play means black has some
options here to to build I just wasn't
sure how to build because I liked all of
his pieces though but I think your move
Rook E3 is actually just
just exactly what the doctor orders play
Rook E3 I said so yes
go Ben bent go Ben yeah all subscribers
to Ben's Channel get the go Ben emotes
out
um
yeah no but oh and by the way guess what
he just played
yeah I saw him play it physically but it
was hard to see but yeah
rookie three
has been played I mean Fabi should be
happy because the guy played a move I
suggested so I mean I'm sure fabi's like
oh Ben suggested that great
but yeah I don't I don't know what to do
here for white it seems to me the only
possible thing white can do is push his
deep one but he really can't go to D6
and he's probably just pushing it to its
Doom right I mean I take E Pawn I
probably just go take the Deep Pawn
later but if you play D6 I mean the
Knight is such a great defender to the
king and and that's a a chess cliche but
it's true I mean you could even just
play this move and then he played D5 but
I I think five is going to lose
and the queen does nothing
the queen just defends G3 that's the
whole point of the queen
that's that's bad yeah
highly unfortunate
for the uh
now that E5 is open for the Black Knight
sometimes we can play rookie 2 and Rook
H5 and 95. that doesn't look good either
so I yeah D5 give let's black play 95
later if it's tracked
well we saw that Fabi has indeed played
D5 on the board
um yeah fobby's not happy no it's this
is not headed no I I yeah and his
opponent's very happy
you can just tell by the body language
this is yeah
yeah Bobby's gonna lose
man just as he you know he sacrificed he
got what he wanted and then he didn't uh
play well with his King his King on G1
just got in terrible trouble
yeah jubabaya has got that confident
pose the uh as we said
the live board now shows he's gobbling
up the E4 Pawn
wow and fun fact if Fabiano loses this
game he can only qualify for next year's
candidates via the grand Swiss
um
or the or the Grand Prix but it's
and and you know I I hate to say this as
as we are you know the organizing
partners of the the Isle of Man uh fide
Grand swiss but we don't even know if
that event is going to happen due to
global pandemic restrictions and and
everything that's happening right now so
he can't get in by raiding the
candidates they don't have one or two
people
there's also wild cards and things but I
yeah yeah it's it's not
yeah they're from what I understand next
next year's candidates will not have any
rating spots it's all up to the system
right and that's not good for Fabi
that's not good for Fabi no
um his opponent's too confident I don't
like that yeah I hate that with my
opponent's confident he's he's way too
confident
why am I winning so easily this is great
it's it's it's nice when it works out
that way because you're you know we knew
he was in trouble the moment you and I
came back because it wasn't just that he
had won the night but back in this
position when we first spotted it it was
that all of Black's pieces are suddenly
just perfectly coordinated like the
Brooks and knights and and close and
close contact on one side of the board
are among the most dangerous Duos in
chess right Brooks and Bishops you know
have have a long distance relationship
that works right you and I used to have
one of those
um that's correct but um no I'm kidding
um
I think I think our long-distance
relationship is working I think this is
working yeah what do you think it's the
long distance that makes it work okay
but the Rook at night The Rook at night
are I mean this is this is exactly what
the doctor ordered and and
White had no chance the queen is like
the queen is just like a helpless piece
yeah
I mean all it's doing is it's defending
the G3 Pawn that's not good
wow there's just never any checks the
Knight on G6 stops all the checks the
Rooks gobble up the d-pawn it's over
highly unfortunate for Fabiano
um yeah White's King is way too open
once that deep Pawn goes that's that was
his counter play was the center points
Fabiano will be the highest rated or
yeah he will be the highest rated player
who's been sent home if and when he
loses this match there have been some
other large upsets but obviously this is
um right I think ferrous is the highest
Trader now but that'll change
is going to win otherwise he'll be sent
home
that's right
um and yes there is no wild card because
remember it's already gone to rajaba due
to everything that happened oh that's
right so yeah the reason so it's
literally
and and what a weird situation to be in
right because it's just part of the
cycle you have your chances to qualify
or not and it's weird when you feel like
the best player in the world who's not
Magnus Carlsen may not even have a
chance to challenge for the title now
again John the Palm that she has
something to say about that come
November right we'll see if he's if he's
uh making a claim for the throne but you
know it's a really wild Dynamic when
these players are not just trying to win
the World Cup everybody they're trying
to keep their chances to play for a
world championship title alive and your
chess career can be short
um you know and fabi's one of those guys
who as we discussed earlier is not
playing hundreds and thousands of games
online right so he's he's studying all
the time probably more than anybody but
his playing over the board if he didn't
play over the board for a year year and
a half yep he's he's not like making up
for it by playing lots of chess online
like the other top players do right he's
like he's chess poor he doesn't play any
chess
no 100 and um
and yeah I think the Pawn's on D6 now I
think he played D6 yeah um and Juma bayf
has come and sat down indeed
um but as you and I already highlighted
kind of simple moves like Rook D5 even I
mean I I just threw that one out there
maybe the engine likes Rook D4 better it
doesn't really matter because the point
is the d-pawn is going nowhere right
yeah I just play both then I play Rick
yeah he's gonna play Rick D4
yeah
yeah and then he's gonna take that pawn
and then Bobby's gonna suffer
yeah
if Bobby looks like he wants to resign
but I don't think he's going to resign
here
he looks very unhappy well because I
mean there's two reasons to be unhappy
losing to a low rated player but I mean
his opponent basically blundered and
fobby was better and then he just got
totally crushed yep that's so to paint
the the story of how fobby holds this
real quick because it's not over the
right the one the biggest problem he
needs to solve is not just that he's
losing his pawns but that his King is in
a mating net yeah his King is in trouble
yeah so one plan Ben is to like just run
and I don't think we should
underestimate that because now that I
look at it removing the kind of the
emotional bias of how we got here
because like you said it is emotional
for probably who was not only winning
but you know uh you know now he's blown
it but if the king runs out and you're
not an amazing net this isn't easy for
black to win because you're you're
always in fear of a Perpetual check
right so what if Bobby plays King G2 you
know I I don't think it's that hard to
win okay so what's give us give us the
clean Place well now your g-pawn's not
not defended so I'll play Rook D3 okay
and I'm just gonna run I guess because I
have no choice
[Music]
um I mean what else okay I guess I guess
I'll play here okay I'll be a little
more accurate and I'll take the I'll
take the Deep one right so now I've got
my queen defending and I'll play King F2
chat Rick D2 check
okay
and I
I guess I run
yeah and then something like wow oh
rookie two yeah well I don't want to put
my kingdom yeah I mean if you go to the
the back rank I'm just gonna back rank
meet you so I'm gonna keep my king alive
yeah
I mean this isn't hard yeah no okay it
is indeed and I guess the biggest
problem is
you know
The King The King's just a sitting dark
and the queen has no tracks yeah
this is this is this is not good yep
all right yeah he's Bobby's very upset
and his opponent's very confident yeah
no I mean fabi's gonna lose
foreign
yeah you can't let the guy play H5 H4
take your knight and then not lose
that's not fair
when you lose your knight when you
didn't have to that's that's disaster
yeah so garam's out looks like fabi's
gonna be out Jeffrey One On Demand
and now savian had that worst ending
against Duda
and he needs to draw that to not get
knocked out they drew the first game
yeah so yeah the uh
the Americans aren't uh doing very well
this round and and you said Carissa was
losing we looked at that a little while
ago yep so not not a good round for the
Americans
yeah it reminds me of the world youth
when we go to the world Youth and I'm
the one of the coaches for The American
Kids yeah the first round's great and
the second round's great and then some
of the rounds aren't great after that as
it gets tougher and tougher and you
start playing the best people in the
world than
yeah but yeah I'm sure Fabi expected to
win this match his opponents so much
more lower rated than he is yep but yeah
that guy's good
byev is good yes Grisha pointed out a
lot of these guys are underrated yep the
world has changed right and I think it's
going to take some time before certain
things settle out because
like grishek said who just joined us
earlier if you missed the interview it's
it's um it's hard to measure the
strength of of of Chess when you've
missed 18 months of over the board play
yeah and uh this is cinderoff Corey
let's see yeah they showed it for a
second yeah yeah we're gonna go back
we're gonna go check out that one that
was the queen versus Rick and Knight and
Corey has to hold that oh he lost his
Knight he's trying to hold this position
he lost his Knight in exchange for a
blockade and the Sendai of uh sendara
game
um yeah we can take a look at corabov's
game we've got we've got core above on
camera it's certainly one of the most
entertaining
um hairdos in the game
um
you know I'm into that
wow he allowed Bishop F3
yeah that looks like and uh I guess he
had so because if he plays Bishop to D1
and King H7 Well gorgeous was paused
there kind of like wait a second uh oh
there goes my winning chances after
Bishop three
remember
um for those
just tuning in quarter above one uh
yesterday uh in day one game one of
round three so a draw here is black is
is effectively a win
um for the match there's still winning
chances because even if I win your C pun
you win my H Pawn I can still win that
and if I can get my king to E7
um
then I can I can take on F7 with my
Bishop because I have H7 you could you
could still win that it's possible
they're still winning chances because
the black king just has to babysit that
H Pawn
no it's a really good point I'll show
I'll show that real quick in a line just
because it's super I mean it should be a
draw but maybe it shouldn't it if this
kind of thing happens no matter no
matter what black does for the remaining
moves a king is going to get to E7
because this king is stuck guarding the
H Pawn and at that time now you have
this idea
that's dribiali and Navara that's what
it looks like on camera Navara wow Derby
Ali won look at the Kings
oh wow yeah dribiali knocked out Navara
it always makes me feel better when
people who completely destroy me then do
well in other events right because I'm
like am I just the worst player ever or
is that guy good Andrea bialy two years
ago in the world open oh man that was
embarrassing
yeah but yeah beating Navara now I feel
better because man if R is good
yeah durabali is is
um
well he's moving on to round four and
wow this this particular match was was
tied headed into this round sir so yeah
I mean that was an upset navara's you
know used to be like 27 30. yep but like
we said there aren't upsets anymore
because we don't know what everyone's
ratings are supposed to be yeah yeah
that's true now Jerry bialy is a very
strong player yeah yeah well there you
go he wins this end game sends Navarro
home
a lot of the games are finishing we see
uh a much less crowded room than we had
earlier today
core above gets up and kind of takes a
stroll I do want to go back to that end
game
durabiali's uh Victory distracted us but
that game with corabov
big implications the uh the winner of
that game will will take on uh Alexander
grishek
in the next round
um
right yeah and also corabov won
yesterday so your gift has to win on
demand yep
but back to what we were saying in this
line there's
There's real potential to win if the
king reaches E7 because you can't win
it's not it's not like a dead draw
there's there's winning chances yeah
Ben's point was that if this position
happens and like Bishop G6 is played
right you take on F7 and then H7 yep and
then you h8 and then you take but then
even I could win this
yeah
I know you could do it Ben yeah no I
mean there's winning chances it's not
like black just closes his eyes and
draws it's it's not going to be an easy
draw of the quarterbox acting like it is
he's walking around like there's no
trouble
yep that would be amazing if your give
wins on demand I mean he's he's not the
youngest player in the tournament
yeah but uh Muhammad yarab just did it
right and uh
and so did uh krasenkov
this is Shanklin with black
he drew the first game was he playing
Duda
uh well no Shanklin is playing
um
or arsachenko oh you can't go yeah yeah
yeah we haven't gotten to look at
shanklin's uh games too much
so I'm pulling up Sam's Sam's game
that's right Judas playing Savion I'm
confusing Americans
yeah
confusing Americans that sounds like a
great a great movie coming out this
looks like a draw great night active
pieces for black
yeah this this looks like a draw
if the draw occurs we will be headed to
tie breaks because our Shinko and
Shanklin Drew their first game
hxb6 has been played
yeah this looks perfectly uh reasonable
King to H1 pretty much the only move now
mm-hmm
I wanna I wanna play
I want to play for tricks like you know
Knight takes G3 Rook H5 check at some
point but I don't see how to ever do
that I don't see how to line that up I I
tried for some tricks like that earlier
in spindler's game versus ship Arena
um but Ethan ephon was the spoiler she
kept pointing out how that it did yeah I
could just never do that if I'd like to
do it but I don't I don't see how to do
that
slide The Rook over and take in two
moves yeah right
if we can cheat a little bit we can win
uh
yeah this looks like it's gonna go to a
tie break
yep okay so it's
if we had to pick who has winning
chances I mean is it black is it
Shanklin I'll pick black just because of
the clock situation right I mean if
that's true it fits 16 minutes to one
okay then you know
I think I think somebody winning means
somebody's gonna blunder so it's going
to be the person with one minute but the
position should be a draw yep
that's right what's Happening Here
um let's see Rook
s good for black
who are these guys I'm trying to
although I can't really see the position
perfectly but black has a lot of past
Pawns
pass pawns on the H file the B file the
a file
all the past pawns you could ever want
things got a lot of past ones you know
past pawns for your heart desire
let's let let's go back to Magnus
Carlson's game because you know you
mentioned
the uh some of the big moments where
Magnus initially endeared himself to the
fans and I I remember fondly the uh the
the grinded out victory over levona Roni
and from the singfield cup obviously we
love you love but the fact that Magnus
didn't take a draw when he had it
clinched he's definitely gonna win this
game that was before he was the world
champion yeah for those right for those
who don't remember it so the reason I
say he endeared himself to fans it was a
big deal at the time because it was like
you know Magnus could have had a draw
but he was showing he was he was going
to be different than other times not
only could he have had a draw aronian
offered him a draw and he didn't take it
right and if he takes it he's clear
first and wins a hundred thousand
dollars right and he's and if he if he
loses he's not clear first and doesn't
win a hundred thousand now there's
drawing and winning was the same amount
of money and same first place clear but
he's like I'm slightly better so he
played on any one right
no so Magnus Magnus playing just like
that and then you obviously mentioned
later when he won the World Championship
in his games against Vichy were
similarly he played on in a position
that could have also probably been been
forced into a draw earlier to win the
match and so you know this is vintage
Magnus Carlson chess and it is the right
mindset right because look you know as a
chess player you want to be in the best
shape at all times and if you think
you're winning keep playing it's easier
said it's definitely going to win this
whether it's winning or not better King
better Bishop better Rook yep I mean
sometimes the exchange sack on e4 wins
because the e-pawn's Unstoppable
sometimes yep especially if you can win
both yeah so but I mean this is just
white has no counter play this is
terrible you'd be afraid if the white
Bishop was on D5 because then there
might be a rook D3 checklist then there
could be a Checkmate he's walking into
yeah white has no way to put the bishop
on D5 and take advantage of this king
without losing the E5 this is just white
suffering and you don't want to suffer
against Magnus that's the wrong person
to suffer against yep
yeah so Magnus could plan forever he's
never going to agree to a draw even
though he could draw right now if he
wanted to say drawing like I would say
yeah
but now it's just a question of whether
he'll win or not and I I expect him to
win right
well I think it's the right mindset to
you know you're thinking big picture
about the whole tournament keep yourself
in shape and like we said right mindset
or not in a long tournament it's the
thing we love about Magnus is that he's
going to play these positions for a win
so uh the thing we love about Ben is
that um well I've already made like
multiple pink shirt jokes so I won't do
that
um you do sometimes have funny puns too
so people do like that about you you
know the problem is uh the last two days
I did
commentary with niriditsky and I gotta
let him do all the puns I can't take
away his fun and now you've got me so
all the awkward moments are taken up by
me so what do you if I could do if I
could do commentary with Yvonne then I
would be the funny one yeah okay all
right well we're gonna take a very quick
break uh when we return We of course
will be following all of these games to
their conclusion don't go anywhere it's
more of chess.com's coverage of the fide
World Cup in just a minute
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
potentially capturing the final moments
of Fabiano caruana's fide World Cup
it just looks like nice trick at the end
Queen takes G2 Rick D2 check that's nice
yeah
and the point is that if the king moves
backwards Rook to D1 is a win if the
king moves to E1 Rook E2 wins the queen
oh yeah and with that
Juma bayev sends the number one rated
American home and puts his chances of
qualifying for the next candidate cycle
in jeopardy
yeah that was not a fun game for Fabi no
absolutely not
and uh
heartbreaking because again it was an
emotional loss from the perspective that
he didn't get outplayed start to finish
he was winning or at least clearly
better at some point right he was in
control of his own destiny before that
kind of dubious king walk
um bringing the king up here to H3 uh
was where uh Ben and I first
uh this was this was not ideal
um and ultimately
Fabiano caruana is headed home
yep somehow black started a big attack
in the end game and it worked yep
well he's still uh you know in many
people's eyes the the strongest player
in the world has been for the last
couple years besides Magnus Carlson uh
but Bobby's headed home and speaking of
Magnus Carlson he does look like he's
going to convert the win against Ariana
um iron's got to be like bro come on
just take the draw it's hard to play
without a king the whole game and black
has the king and white doesn't so
yeah he did something really nice just
before we went just after he went to
break he played C4 which was explosive
and white had to decide whether to give
up his e-pawn and then black plays you
know E4 E3 E2 or take with a B Pawn and
probably get mated Rick h8 that doesn't
look good Rook comes back and there's no
way that doesn't look good no what a
what a horrible move so he took with the
bishop King E4 and I mean the F7 Pawn
doesn't matter so here comes the E Pawn
Here Comes now that matters yeah
yeah I mean white has a better black has
a better Bishop King and rook and a past
Pawn the other past pawns for white
can't do anything
moves like one E4 oh sorry not E4 Rook
D1 is what could be met just by King C3
and then push that pawn yeah yep
[Music]
um
so what exactly is White gonna do here
well he's gonna lose that's what he's
gonna do
that's what he's gonna do yeah
um just thanks for always finishing my
uh you know you know
no but Magnus wants to win 2-0 because
he wants to feel like okay I want all my
games and my in my opponents are like
damn Magnus one two zero that's not good
they want to see Magnus struggling they
don't want to play him after he's super
confident yep
man talk about body language yeah well
we've got uh another game that just
finished speaking of body language who
are those generals that looks like you
and and tabatsa bay are I'm pronouncing
it wrong but uh that's who those guys
look like
um
yeah and you lost yesterday he had to
win yesterday so unless he won that game
he's also headed back home to China and
he did not so uh
tell me to see you later to you young
Ying there's an upset for you yeah
um
Thomas is uh Rising uh player from Iran
and uh becoming more and more of a
household name not just all the reason
for Arusha and Parham mag Sulu also a
very very strong player I'm surprised to
see you Yong Yi I feel like he's always
like a dark horse pick when we talk
about the the skill sets of all time
controls he's so also a bit of rapid and
Blitz but but no he is he is no longer
dancing and he'll be headed back to
China
we see Magnus again getting closer so C3
track it was King Samir
but that's one of his past pawns he
needed
and Magnus is like yeah whatever
yeah that's unfortunate yeah because if
if if white plays King C2 here Magnus
will probably play Bishop E3 and then
Rook H2 check and I I don't like that
yeah well no matter what you understand
the Rook The Rook comes to H2 you'll
have to go back to B1 the bishop on E3
really kills The Rook on F3 boom
yep well we'll see if he plays Bishop E3
or he plays a better move
I guess he could play E4 also because
that stops Rook D3 check maybe E4 is
better well we gotta wait for King C2 to
be played he did play it I could see on
the live board
he played King to C2 yep
yeah it's either Bishop E3 or E4
Magnus is like wow this is Pleasant
yeah I uh yeah E4 to get to the live
position I can't see King stitches hold
on we're going to refresh yeah he played
E4
yeah so wait King D4 was played King C2
right E4 Rook F2
Rook F2
this is the live position
um
but uh yeah I mean this magnet's just
gonna win
um everything's better
everything's better
man he's so mean he played Bishop B4
he's just I mean white just can't move
there's no moves
I mean now that Magnus can probably win
if he's allowed Rook H1 to A1
that white can't move
yeah this is this is just what do you
want me to say it's not my fault that
Magnus is so good yeah no no this that
was a really Magnus kind of position
yeah it really was yeah and uh the Atari
might resign now there's just there's no
move
there's nothing to do
man I wanted to play Bishop H5 to D1
stopping The Rook maneuver but The
Bishop's hanging on H5
man I want to stop the I guess Bishop C4
to F1 and then E3 is winning yeah yeah
no he should resign here there's there's
nothing to play design
and as much as you wish this was a draw
but I guess also from a rating points
perspective ariantari does not get any
no yeah yeah no Magnus isn't taking a
draw when he's even a little better
because that's that's not who he is he
thinks it's like a sin against chess to
have a big advantage and agree to a draw
he's like a big Advantage you gotta keep
playing
that that's what chess is
now this is definitely resignable he's
just there's just no legal moves
yep
speaking of rating points carwana drops
below 2 800 For the First Time March
2018 which is I mean as a guy who we
just know is just
I mean he
let's remember he didn't actually lose
in classical to Magnus in 2018 right I
mean this is the guy who is has been the
best player in the world not named
Carlson for for the last five years I
mean almost undeniably but yeah uh if
Bobby's struggling a little bit right
now we know he'll bounce back but uh
obviously not the way he wanted his
campaign and Sochi to end
um
let's let's look at the game with uh
with Mama Jara because we keep talking
about players who need to win on command
and it looks like the shock
the shock is uh this is definitely
winning yeah
daddy shock dude
daddy shock yeah I mean white spawns are
all defended and once you take the B
Pawn you're just queen and the black
king isn't doing anything and whites up
a pawn yeah white has everything yeah
so that's going to go into tie breaks
so yeah Mama John's gonna win on demand
Jeffrey Zhang One On Demand
and um Carissa's opponent can I
pronounce her name she won on demand too
I guess
she also got on command
yeah it's funny when you yeah when you
lose the first game and you have to win
the second one it happens a lot they
they fight hard King to G8 is that what
he played King G7
okay I was like a king G7 I I barely
understand so that's good
but okay I'm this is definitely a
position where White's pushing to win
but I'm sitting here trying to find
where's the concrete plan if you if you
bring the Rook to B2 and try to take
you're always losing the Jeep on
um
[Music]
oh this is a nice move you know why he's
he's preventing the king from hiding and
improving because then Rook D6 will go
to a winning King upon ending that's
right yeah so King C7 is a very nice
move by mamajarov
um but we also have the shirov's game
just ended the sheer off game just ended
but I don't I don't know what happened
let's see what's happening all I know is
I don't want to go out on a limb here
but was Alexi Sheriff rocking a mullet
what is going on with that hairdo
I haven't seen anything like that since
Conair
right and actually
Nick Cage looked even crazier in his
latest movie which I did see Pig
they said he hasn't looked like that
since Con Air
oh my gosh well shout out to Anna and
butter who hit the cube right at the
right moment but what is going on with
that hairdo Alexi wheat yeah so they
drew they they drew because the kings
are on those squares yeah so that means
unfortunately sure I was out share off
the former world number two
um is also going home here in round
three you know this
this a top poker player and I watch his
stream sometimes he's like 13 1400 on
chess.com he plays a lot of chess
somebody in the chat said why why is
your hair like that he has very long
hair and he said I don't have a job and
I have a lot of money so I don't have to
get a haircut if I don't want to foreign
I don't have to go somewhere and work I
don't want to get hurt
that's hilarious
um
well okay Alexis shirov is headed home
we see another game finish is that Sam
sabian's game indeed yeah did Sam hold
the drawer did he lose I'm I'm trying to
pull it up oh my gosh JKD got the job
done and John Kristoff sends uh yeah
those things that day for the Americans
yes yes
Ray of laws Carolina lost and the truth
hurts in in karissa's case Chris and
jeong's case young one divorce tiebreak
and karissa's case she's still alive she
lost today but she was a full game up in
the match so she will have tie breaks
um
but uh
yeah uh Wild Wild games I actually
depending on how much time we have
unfortunately you know that we can only
cover so many games which is why we tell
you to go to chess.com events and choose
your own flavor but I would I would love
to sit here and spend a whole bunch of
time analyzing what happened because
this game oh it did go to the king upon
any you called it Ben yeah we talked
about this happening and I thought black
would be okay by cleaning his Pawn but
they both cleaned their pawns and he
lost his King side wait it was this
position and I was curious about whether
your threat was strong enough to play E5
and turns out it was
um sevian played E5 but we we
foreshadowed it well in saying that the
the issue of this is that now every King
and pawn ending is lost and
and that's kind of what happened here
ultimately probably the threat of
entering the kingdom punt ending keeps
black passive and there you go he goes
into a kingdom punt ending and guess who
wins young Christophe dudas so the queen
and then those pawns are just all
falling
I feel like you and I predicted that
game together that was a team effort I
mean I don't want to take any credit
from you but I also helped man Queen A4
is awesome it defends the F Pawn because
the queen A7 check yep you can't it
defends the epon so now it's time to
take Black's pawns that's great wow
no seriously this is a fantastic move it
defends E4 directly it defends F2
dynamically because of the skewer on A7
and just like that young Kristoff
finds a way to convert look at that he
gets every poem with check he's so mean
yeah a dirty dog
it's just torture wow and goes on to win
so a fantastic game from the number one
player in Poland
and we have another game up right now
I'm gonna try to pull it up what game is
that whose game is that
all right Magnus one even if I didn't
see him win he won
Agnes wins
looks like they've shaken hands King to
C5 and it hasn't even registered yet on
the the dgt relay but that's because the
Arbiter hasn't put the King on the board
yeah black is obviously winning here up
a piece yep
um well shout out to Matt that's that's
funny Danny in the final position there
if Magnus plays King takes Rook at
stalemate
oh wow that's why he put that's why he
gave his Bishop away on F1 he was hoping
for still that's funny oh my God that's
so cool shout out to Tori yeah look at
this rookie two Eric Rosen oh no my Rook
and if you take it's stalemate
tricks are for kids
but look at this just King C5 and now
there's no stalemate trick as you give
the king the D3 yeah the King has the D3
squares you can't you can't play this
anymore everybody because because you
just take it nope
wow that was that was a nice trick but
you know it was a nice trick you got to
give him credit for that it'd be good
for bullet chest not so good for slow
shots right
well unfortunately for Ari antari he
will be uh he'll be headed home Magnus
remains perfect like we said vintage
Magnus showing up there in Sochi and
we'll see how far how far he can ride
this video World Cup but right now
Carlson looks to be in great form
um hancrotoff is the game that also uh
has has one of the players in a muslin
scenario that being that being uh Pavel
pankrado as we said and he looks like he
should be able to convert this he's up
the exchange right
let's see Rook B5
yeah I mean this should be winning
it's it's not super easy but I mean up
at exchange and upon the black king is
an amazing net so
he might want to play like you know King
E4 Rook H7 threading Rook B6 mate
and uh also queening the F Pawn is a
good idea so he's got a lot of
a lot of the things that look good he
also the last move am I missing
something oh The Rook is defending the
bishop yeah he can't he can't move his
Rook off the bishop because Rook B6
check wins immediately right then if
King takes Rook B5 check
so he's he's not really threatening Rick
takes H3
because then Rick B6 wins it instantly
right no it's a good point the point is
that Black's pieces are a lot more
Frozen than first meets the eye right
you can't move anything because you'll
get something captured yep if you take
then we just check twice and and right
and luckily he's stopping King E4
because he can play Rook E3 check and go
back yep yeah so he played Rook G3
and
Rook h8 okay but but now okay you still
can't take because just the checks
wait can can you no
yes
if rookie I would be very afraid to take
but I would be more afraid not to take
it yeah
I don't see the immediate win of the
bishop so I have to ask and indeed uh
makidov's gonna ask the same question
how am I losing here
right well black could swing his Rook he
could try to win another way he could
swing his Rook over to A8 and try to
give the you know the two Rook mate ah
look at that and then he's got an F Pawn
in case it doesn't work he's like okay
I'll clean my F1
no I think I think that's the move
because now The Rook is here there's no
checks or anywhere yeah and if you play
if you move the Bishops you have the
king G5 F6 is discovered check and it's
defended so that's risky you check the
king runs F6 check in fact look at this
look at this check look how sweet that
is yeah yeah that's funny and then you
just give the true Rook mate yeah
that's what you get for having the Rook
on H3 you know yeah
so Rook to G8 oh actually he played Rook
G8 instead of Rook A8 but also looks
very strong oh man Rick G6 check and
Rick B6 check are both threats yeah I
don't like this yeah that's that's not
good
I mean it's good for white
yeah this is definitely an easy win
these games are finishing and rapid fire
but we're going to be here to the very
end so don't go anywhere we've got punk
Rod off in this position remember he has
to win so doing so is going to have uh
Ben and I doing uh well I mean what
we'll be doing commentary tomorrow on
the tie breaks of this match looks like
um the
the game between irishenko and Shanklin
is still rolling we can head over there
because we've got them on camera
what's happening in the world of Sam
Shanklin besides experimental facial
hair we're gonna find out
I remember little Sammy when he couldn't
grow a beard someone clip it and ship it
to him
um clip it and ship it wow clip and ship
it on Twitter that's what the cool kids
say they tweet do you tweet
you talking to me are you twittering oh
yeah I Twitter a lot are you twittering
young man yeah
well but Black's the only one who can
win it should be a draw
but you know white has less time and
White's King is
not as safe as Black's King the B3 pawns
weak it's a draw but you know white
could make a mistake white has to be
more accurate than black and with the
time situation that's hard to do yep
you got to be careful here with white
the queen and Knight are are such a
tricky Duo especially in time pressure
to deal with and
and part of that is the queen and Bishop
are very good at ganging up on on a
static Point everybody but the queen at
night can create weaknesses together
because the knights ability you know to
switch to one color and attack right and
then switch to another color and attack
so sometimes you're you're evaluating
the Practical the Practical Dynamic of
the pieces and the Queen and Knight have
the ability to create problems under
time pressure in ways that the queen and
Bishop don't necessarily I like Queen E1
not only does it attack the Knight it
also attacks the pawn on A5 yep I like
that the bishop on B7 stopping Knight F3
forever indeed so yeah that's that's a
nice that's a nice defensive move Queen
E1
it defends G3 attacks the Knight attacks
the pawn defends the second rank that's
a good thing of six the queen will
probably come back to F2 yeah now this
will be a draw I don't think our chenko
can is gonna blunder
yeah we'll so we'll see we'll see more
tie breaks
more tie breaks yeah lots of one ones
but this very fighting one one
we want tie breaks we want prenup we
gotta take a break real quick when we
come back we're gonna we're gonna see a
lot of these games reach their
conclusion
um maybe
or we'll we'll get Ben to guess on which
game is going to keep us here for seven
hours find out hang on the edge of your
seat we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
special treat here we are now joined by
world champion Magnus Carlson who who
got a victory that that you had me and
Ben talking Magnus about uh about your
your victories over levonne aronian from
the singfield cup way back and and other
games where you where you play on in a
situation where you only needed a draw
right are you doing it doing it because
you feel like it's the right thing to do
do you do it for the fans how what was
going through your mind as you're
grinding out that Victory when all you
needed was a draw to move on
no I thought there was very very little
risk of losing uh so that that's that
was the main reason
also I really feel like I need practice
in classical chess since I haven't
played
um played much at all in the in the last
one and a half years yeah uh so yeah
also since I'm playing a world
championship later the Sarah I I really
needed uh needed to practice so in that
sense it's uh it's good to play some
some longer games
yeah it makes sense you know Ben was
also commenting on that point seeing
Acro across the room Fabiano Fabiano
caruana lost uh to dream about event and
is going home and and on that note do
you feel that a lot of the top players
are maybe in the same mindset of trying
to work out some of the rust some of the
Kinks because obviously playing over the
board chess is different than than the
online events and is is that part of
your mindset right now just to really
shake off the rust of not having not
played over the board in a while
oh yeah for sure
um I I feel like I'm still uh a little
bit iffy some sometimes especially
yesterday I was was a uh a bit
nervous but uh yeah I'm hope I'm hoping
to to sort of play myself
um into form hopefully I can get get a
lot of get a lot of games
Ben yeah Magnus I I just wanted to
congratulate you along with the other
players this event seems a lot more
interesting
um because there's so many good players
and the games are interesting because we
don't see any of those really quick
draws so this is this is becoming really
exciting for everybody and I'm wondering
if um you're surprised at all by how
well some of the younger players are
doing or more surprised it's how some of
the older players are doing in their 50s
and they're still in the tournament
yeah I think it just goes to to show
that uh there are a lot of strong
players and also
two games is it's a really small sample
size so the variance is going to be
quite uh quite High
um
obviously like everybody else have been
very impressed with
um with uh with Cinderella and the way
he's he's got it's gone about
um and it seems it seems to be the same
in in all of these uh World Cups that
there there's always
are going to be so probably several
breakouts breakout Stars uh and uh looks
like he's a good candidate to be the one
one here
um but
as as I said
very a lot a lot of a lot of very tough
well-prepared opponents uh here and I
don't think anybody can can feel sort of
comfortable in any any around especially
from now
what makes you feel do you feel more
comfortable when everybody's top 10 top
20 in the world which a lot of the round
Robins are or I think the fans like it
better when the top players mix it up
with people who are 100 200 points lower
rated because they're trying more to win
I think and they have an advantage being
better players and the games are more
interesting
um than just playing all the top players
in the world or do you do you enjoy just
playing the better players because
that's more of a test for you
um no as you said in a way it's much
easier to play the same guys that I I
usually play because I know them know
them well and I don't feel feel that
pressure to to win uh always so I can I
can it's easier to play or your own uh
own game
um but
no in general
yeah in general these events are they're
a lot of fun because you get to to do
something else
and
even though
um yeah even though
there are challenges to to playing to
playing these slightly uh some of these
slightly unfamiliar players there's
still it's in any way
um it's not 100 negative not to face the
same the same players and to to bang
your head against
Berlin walls or or similar every time so
I mean it's well we uh we greatly
greatly appreciate your time Magnus you
are you are currently the you are the
only player to have won all their games
so far in in either section and so we we
wish you the best of luck I know I speak
for everyone and that we hope to see you
playing in Sochi all the way all the way
till the end and um best of luck in
round four enjoy enjoy two rest days
what are you gonna do with two rest days
what's the plan
um hopefully I'll go for uh for a hike
in the month and it's like I I injured
my foot playing football uh one and a
half weeks ago hopefully it's it's about
fine now so that I can do that I will
say however the last time I played the
World Cup
um I was the only player at for a note
and I I lost the third round so we're
hoping
um it's not gonna not gonna happen again
well well good luck uh we don't want to
jinx you enjoy enjoy the football and uh
thank you again thank you again for
joining us thanks Magnus that was a
great game Agnes
all right well there you have the world
champion that was awesome to catch up
with Magnus and uh you can tell he I can
tell he's in a zone right now Ben and
you see you see the way he answered my
question or or even made went out of his
way to make that last comment that last
time he played he was undefeated and
lost so he's aware he's aware of just
how hard it is to win this bleeping
tournament right winning the World Cup
like like he just said is such a
challenge right winning the World Cup is
such a hard thing to do but he seems to
be in a zone right now so
fun for the fans
yeah looks like I think Mama Gerard was
winning this position
um so he'll tie up the match if I'm
right and georgiev couldn't win against
corabov that was a draw so georgiev is
out yep yeah this is definitely winning
it's two against zero sorry yeah he's
won the F1
um yeah which means which means it's
it's truly just a matter of technique
um I'm switching the board over to Mom
and Yara of my apologies for that we had
a
a lot of games going on here but there
you go Mama Jara is um
is going to be converting this recorder
yeah
this shouldn't be difficult
it was nice to have magnets I feel like
we could have kept talking about the
online to OTV transition because so much
has happened here and you know um get
his thoughts on what grishek said about
all the underrated players but I think
he kind of answered the question right
he knows that like you said cindarov is
maybe the breakout story this year but
it seems to happen all the time at the
World Cup and now the pandemic has maybe
doubled that factor of just how
underrated some players can be he didn't
say anything about Fabi losing even
though you mentioned it he didn't he
didn't touch that topic yeah
well yeah and it's probably because I
asked I asked a question that sort of
included just you know that everyone's
trying to work out their Kinks and I
think he was just sort of kind of
focusing on yeah like you know he's he's
working on his tanks and and obviously
it's a tough task for everyone but
but uh but yeah
um
Mama jar of converting this one
what other games are still going in the
open section before we maybe check in on
the women's section
yeah at four
there can't be a lot of games left okay
I I don't see any other games I'm just
thinking maybe maybe there aren't any
there can't be a lot
yeah
I'm sure the twitch chat knows who else
is playing
yeah but we also have the the women's
section even if this is the only game
left in the open section so don't go
anywhere just yet we still got more
um
although not sure how many more
interviews we will have hard to top the
world champion joining us but we'll see
if we can catch up with anybody else
remember everybody this win is huge
because mama yarov is winning on command
this is the game needed to send it into
tie breaks versus monirosian
wow he changed his mind as he was moving
that was weird
yes it's not like other games where you
can't like shoot someone like you know
in football or basketball there's no
crossover you know
yeah this is funny I I I had a similar
position to this that was actually drawn
but this one is not where you just keep
attacking the pawns and white you know
if white gets his King to the queen side
here like C6 C7 then it's actually a
draw
right and that's it's a it's a
theoretical draw that I actually knew
and I drew Ron Burnett in like the 80
the sixth U.S junior Championship that
has lost the whole game but I got to
this drawn ending but Marty rosian
throws in the towel though right right
and not not this position yeah well I
was just about to highlight the ways
that can happen because it it does
happen and it's unlikely but it you know
you can blow these endings if uh if you
separate the king of the pawns too far
or like you said you misplaced the Rook
but yes at this point all white has to
do is slide The Rook over and start
pushing the king back so it was easy
yeah
so he wins on demand in a very long end
game and he's gonna play tie breaks
tomorrow
good for shock and um we have
other games potentially going still in
the uh the women's section I'm gonna
flip over there and and find
where we are Elizabeth's position gets
better and better every time we look at
it
yeah is this game still going or did she
win it is still going so we have a
little yeah but this is uh against mama
doba I mean Bishop A3 next move so
I mean
maybe it's not going
if the King was Bishop A3 and that's
that's the end of the game
all right we're going to take a very
quick Break
um it was uh
it was the last game in the open section
here between mama darv and Marty Roshan
we will return and dive into the games
that remain in the women's section so
don't go anywhere the final games and
final moments of the second set of games
of round three of the feeding World Cup
when we return
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
boy did we have it all today been uh
exciting Games Crazy finishes some
heartbreaking uh moments for a couple of
Americans an interview with the world
champion but uh before we dive in and
preview what's ahead for tomorrow and
remind everybody of the tie breaks your
uh your favorite moment of the day
besides my besides my Kanye lyrics I
slipped in that nobody caught besides no
I caught that oh yeah I knew what you
were doing okay um I mean
told me we're gonna interview two
players before the round which two I
think we got the two Shook and Carlson
that's that's some good interviews there
yep um I was really impressed that
Magnus kept pressing and pressing and
pressing when it wasn't really necessary
it does make sense he playing the World
Championship soon so he wants to get
some chess in and yep you know when he's
better he plays for the win and I think
I mean those those guys are you know and
it was impressive that Mama jarov went
on demand Jeffrey won on demand yeah
there was a lot of that Chris is a poem
about one on demand there were I mean a
lot of people went on demand yeah yeah
so yeah they're going to be a lot of tie
breaks tomorrow in the in the open
section yep
um 11 in total yeah 11 total tie breaks
tomorrow there are four tiebreakers in
the women's section right
um the field has been whittled down
um to uh 65 I believe that's uh total
participants remaining
um
so we're we're continuing to get get
through it let's remind everybody of
what is in store for tomorrow because uh
the tiebreakers if you skip to the
second line there they start with rapid
which is the same tiebreaker used in the
World Chess Championship for our serious
chess fans who know that uh the second
tie break if it continues to be a tie uh
is then 10 minutes with a 10 second
increment and then we ultimately move
into a blitz tiebreaker uh which you
know at that point it's it's no longer
you know classical or even rapid chest
which is what people see most the time
with with super high stakes but at that
point something has to happen so they do
Blitz and still if we don't have a clear
winner we will finally get Armageddon
don't forget in round three we had two
matches that went to Armageddon those
were crazy I was commentating for those
that was nuts you don't see matches Ben
for tens of thousands of dollars let
alone if you win the whole thing with a
six-figure prize often decided with like
with time scrambles where people are
knocking over pieces but it does happen
sometimes so
um schedule let's remind everybody we
will be here tomorrow uh once again
bright and early for those on the west
coast depending on where you are
um it is July 19th today so tomorrow's
the 20th uh then there is a rest day on
the 21st but we will see you tomorrow on
July 20th and uh along with uh myself
and our amazing team of commentators we
will we will be joined for the first
time during our feeding World Cup
coverage by the one and only
vishwanathon Anand um who Ben you sure
you reminded me of a great story I want
to tell everybody before we go the first
time Vichy ever joined a show on
chess.com
Ben and I were doing commentary and this
was years ago and Vichy had won an
incredible game one of the best games
we'd ever seen him play and Ben was like
you want to see if we can get Vichy on
the on the phone
and and then Vichy just joined us on
Skype because you just you uh at that
point I had only just gotten I had
barely gotten to know bushy so I didn't
have him on a personal you know call US
Cellular but you got him on the on the
on the show you remember that
yeah I I just on Skype if you remember
what Skype was people what hey did she
did you want to wanna look at your game
with us being Danny live on chess.com
he's like sure and I said okay Danny
he's coming on now and you're like what
and then that was his game against aroni
and I I think it was 2013 from 2013. he
won his 2013 he won his what an amazing
yeah
and remember the thing about Vichy is
the guy is such a legend in terms of his
preparation that he won that game
against aronian as black with prep that
he had prepared for I think he said to
Paula for chromic it was it was I think
it was for the the 2010 World
Championship match and he said he never
got to use it so three years later he
uses it to crush a Roney with the black
pieces that was an amazing game yeah
man remember when you and I were that
good at chess in our past lives remember
that no okay okay well anyway this has
been a lot of fun and and uh if you're
if you're uh just tuning in you missed
the show but go ahead and check out the
full video replay on behalf of my uh my
whole crew here the production team
working hard our mods my two
co-commentators hoey Fawn and the
legendary Ben Feingold
um thanks for tuning in and we will see
you tomorrow on chess.com TV with more
feed a World Cup coverage goodbye
everybody bye everybody
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you